and i believe that you have a short
statement that you would like to make
to the committee so if you could make
your brief introduction and the
statement
uh please thank you
mr chairman my name is lex greensell
thank you for the opportunity to
participate in this
important hearing to answer your
questions and i hope to provide clarity
and
greater understanding of the issues
before us
please understand that i bear complete
responsibility for the collapse of
greensville capital
i am desperately saddened that more than
a thousand
very hard-working people have lost their
jobs at greensell
likewise i take full responsibility
for any hardship being felt by our
clients and their suppliers
and indeed investors in our programs
it's deeply regrettable that we were let
down
by our leading insurer whose actions
assured greenville's collapse and indeed
by some of our biggest customers
to all of those affected by this
i am truly sorry
thank you very much for that could i
take you back to a very specific moment
in time to the 12th of july
2019 when you had a meeting in your
offices just off the
strand i believe with lord miners i
believe this was a meeting or he
described as being about an hour and a
quarter but whatever length it was it
was a fairly lengthy
uh meeting and when he gained evidence
to this committee
uh he uh left us strongly with the
impression that he had had a meeting
with you in which he had expressed
disquiet
about the business model that you were
following
he told us that when he left the meeting
uh when he'd gone down in the lift
afterwards and he was thinking about it
into his mind came the idea that uh what
was going on here was uh
and i am paraphrasing him tantamount to
a ponzi scheme as he described it
um could you just tell the committee a
little bit about
that meeting uh what kind of
concerns lord miners raised with you
about the structure of the business and
the model of business
uh as it was and what uh answers you
were
able to provide him to try and reassure
him
that actually green sill was a viable
and uh
and sensible business so mr chairman
i i think i would say at the outset that
uh i was very surprised to hear the
evidence
that lord miners provided to this
committee two weeks ago
and it is not consistent with my
recollection
of the events
my recollection of the events and i have
checked my records
before addressing you today is that
lord miners was the chairman of edelman
who was a
communications firm that represented
my firm and through them
he requested a an appointment with me
and you're correct that uh that he met
with me uh on
the 12th of july uh 2019
that was in response to questions that
he had raised
in the house of lords concerning
the the way in which certain
open-ended investment vehicles operated
and the liquidity that they provided and
the mismatch
between those and and the underlying
assets
we had that meeting uh obviously it was
a meeting we took incredibly seriously
given
um lord miners position and and the
positions that he previously held
i felt that we had a constructive
discussion where
i was able to discuss and explain
the differences between uh the
assets that he had been talking about in
his questions that he had
raised in parliament and those
of working capital finance or supply
chain finance assets
which have importantly different
characteristics largely because
the duration or the period of time that
the the assets
are outstanding is very short they match
receivables
uh which get paid very very quickly um
and so
self-liquidate um i thought we had a
constructive uh discussion uh
and we talked about uh um the fact that
as we grew
um we were going to move into um ever
more regulated spaces he noted
um as i told him about our plans for the
future
that we really didn't have any advisers
or directors
with any substantive regulatory
experience
and i suggested to him that we could
benefit from his experience
and he seemed very amenable to that um i
said that
he clearly would want to do more work to
to understand our business
and indeed that was followed with a
subsequent meeting that he had
together with my chairman uh on the 3rd
of september
but i think uh an important detail sorry
let's
stop you there just on that point so the
meeting on the third of september with
the chairman are you saying that lord
miners
miners uh attended that specifically
with the purpose of discussing the
potential
uh potentially joining your board or
joining as an advisor
of green zone was that the reason that
and
clearly continuing his diligence in
understanding our business
and uh and our activities but i i would
like to read
to you if i may mr chairman um
a statement which was sent to me that
was prepared
by law miners after our meeting on the
12th of july
that he proposed to make but in fact we
collectively decided
not to publish that statement simply
because the reality was
the matter was practically closed
however i think it's now relevant for me
to read
you that statement uh that lord miners
uh provided um to uh to us
in in writing um my question i'll read i
quote and this was provided on the 13th
of july
my my question in parliament was linked
to open-ended funds and illiquidity
i've asked many other questions of the
same issue
in my time in parliament in the light of
press commentary
i took it upon myself to meet with lex
greensell
to discuss his business i found him very
open
and following the meeting i am
comfortable with the business
and its operations i heard and saw
nothing
that would warrant the use of the word
fraudulent
or anything similar
he then he then met with
with my chairman and i on the 3rd of
september
he then subsequently attended i believe
it was a breakfast
with just my chairman on the 18th of
september
and wrote a very complimentary note
directly to me afterwards
which i can share with the committee if
required
and and then on the 7th of october
lord miners wrote to my chairman and i
and i will read that short email to you
if i may
dear lex and morris congratulations on
securing further backing
from softbank a powerful endorsement
from a global investor of standing
last week i had a coronary angiogram
at hammersmith hospital the consultant
surgeon
has advised me to reduce my workload
in the circumstances i think i must
decline your interesting idea
and not waste your time by commencing
any detailed diligence i wish you well
regards paul okay
can i just go back to the statement that
you read us
uh from lord miners just to be
absolutely clear
is that a statement that he produced and
provided to
you in other words it was authored by
his own hand in one form or another
it was sent to me by hillman and they
said that it was sent to them
by lord miners and can you tell us who
this middle
person is uh yes i i would be happy to
provide that in writing subsequent to
to this discussion okay fine going back
to that
meeting on the 12th of july was there
anybody else present in that meeting
other than yourself and all miners
no the meeting of the 12th of july was
simply lord miners a night
okay on the 2nd of november lord miners
i noticed submitted a another written
question uh in the house this time about
uh bounce back loans but and also
probing the issue of uh
gfg uh alliance etc so
he certainly at that point which of
course is after the 7th of october when
he broke off the discussions with you i
guess was
back to being concerned about it um
is that all right all right do carry on
you got 2019
mr i beg your pardon you're quite right
um it's not 2019's 2020.
i think you'll find mr german that uh
lord miners uh didn't actually
submit any further questions concerning
greenville capital
until the 22nd of june 2020
so 11 months after he met with me
when he met with your chairman uh lex on
the
third and i think again on the 18th for
the breakfast
was that uh do you have minutes of the
of those meetings did the chairman keep
a record of what was discussed do you
have any
correspondence around the setting up of
that meeting uh particularly in respect
of
what the purpose of the meeting was for
which i think you're suggesting was to
further discussions about lord miners
potentially
becoming involved with green cell in
some form
uh i can certainly look and see what
correspondence and and
material we have available and come back
to you in writing on that mr shannon
okay all right well thank you for that
uh
for that uh evidence can i ask you sort
of more more general question then what
what in your view
went wrong why did uh green cell
fail uh at the end of the day what were
the reasons for that
yes the ultimate failure of green cell
was for one reason but as ever there are
always
associated reasons the reason that
greensoul ultimately failed is because a
material portion
of our funding mr chairman is provided
by investors who require
insurance together with that asset that
they purchase
um to protect them against the default
of that
of of the the underlying receivables
our principal insurance provider
decided not to renew their insurance
despite being in discussions around
renewing their insurance
up to the hours before ultimately credit
suisse
determined they no longer would fund our
business which was roughly a week before
we went into administration
um and it was that withdrawal of
insurance capacity
which resulted in our failure now of
course
mr chairman that the reason you
i'm sure you will ask me what was the
reason for the withdrawal of
that insurance capacity and i think that
really comes down to
uh three things first
covert it had an impact on the entire
insurance industry
and on specific customers of ours and
indeed
i recognize that this body is
considering
what uh changes may be necessary to
regulation
and i have some views about uh which you
may wish
on that lex what precise date was the
insurance cover
terminated uh within the arrangement
uh it's expired at the beginning of
march
uh 2021. right
okay and so
uh so the the first is uh covert had an
impact
both on the insurance industry itself
and on many of our customers
two as you'll be aware we did have
some concentrations and indeed those are
a source of regret to me
with respect to some of our larger
customers which no doubt you'll want to
talk about
um and three uh the actions
of our the regulator of
greensville bank in germany and created
uncertainty
with respect to our ability to continue
to support and provide liquidity
for the key for a key customer that
relied upon us okay
if we sort of look at what's out there
or was out there in the public domain
i'm thinking now 2019 uh basically
uh sort of if you were looking from the
outside and you were
uh looking for things that might cause
concern about
the business on the 18th of march the ft
reported that tim hayward who you'll be
familiar with was was fired from
gam one of the investors providing
finance to uh the business um
and who provided i think hundreds of
millions of dollars in financing
and look at the links tim harwood uh had
with yourself and sanjeev gupta
we then have the various written
questions from law miners we have one on
the 10th of june
on the 7th of july 2019 reporter reuters
reported that greensold issued
false statement on gupta bonds relating
to guarantees provided by the scottish
government on the 8th of july analysts
and bloggers stephen clapham and mark
rubinstein
wrote a blog on the greens on green sill
entitled green sill softbank and
cooking the books um we then have
uh on the 4th of may so we skip forward
to 2020 now
uh ft reports that greenstall had
suffered a raft of client defaults
and the green sun and credit insurers
were having to cover losses in funds
managed by
credit suisse then we have a number of
additional
during june and as we've already
mentioned in november on the second and
the 18th questions from
lord miners what was your reaction to
all of those things well and at what
point did you in that timeline
perhaps think there's something going on
here in this business that i'm getting
really quite concerned about
sure so if one were to think about the
the year of 2020 uh i i guess there were
a number of things that
uh at various points uh registered
concern
uh with with with me when i go back to
2019 though
what were you feeling back at the time
that uh
tim hayward was fired from gam and there
were suggestions of a
close relationship between him and grins
green sill and yourself and
you know the details what uh what were
you thinking at that point if i can take
you back a bit earlier than 2020
well i i can't comment on
matters as between mr hayward and his
employer uh
what i would note is that in fact every
investor
in any of his funds received more than
power
um and there was no loss on any assets
associated
with greensville capital uh by by gam
but i think any matter concerning stay
with himself
i i can't uh i can't specifically
comment on
um and and i think you'll find that that
event actually didn't take place in 2019
but that took place
before that um but uh so
i think he was he was dismissed was he
not uh in march 2019 or thereabouts
actually february i think the 21st of
february announces the firing of tim
haywood
for gross misconduct
so let's get back to the question so the
question the number the question is at
what point
along this timeline from early 2019
onwards do you start to think this
business is
is not really as stable as i would like
it to be and i've got growing concerns
about it what was the moment in time
when that
came to your mind would you say sure
i think the the first event that gave me
concern although not for our company
because we just recently received
more than a billion dollars worth of of
equity investment into our company
but i certainly had reservations and
concerns
about the state of the capital markets
during march april and may 2020
you'll appreciate as and if you cast
your mind back uh you'll remember that
the the capital markets at that time
were
roiled uh by um the uncertainty of
of covert and none of us knew what
was going to come next as it as uh as
you're probably aware
although green saw was funded by
more than 50 banks and several
dozen institutional investors and
one didn't know what was going to happen
in the future
as it was we were able to continue to
support all of the supply chains
and meet every suppliers requirement
throughout the uh the disruption that
took place then
but we didn't know no one knew what was
going to happen next
are you basically saying then so during
2019
largely you were you were aware of
various rumblings going on and press
um adverse press comments etc some of
which we've touched on but you were
basically
um feeling uh positive about the
business it was really once the
pandemic struck so around little bit
earlier than me i guess
that you start to think hold on a minute
this might not be as stable
as i would like it to be would that be a
fair summary actually i would say
that for our business
didn't require that liquidity that
liquidity armor is speaking of
and the conditions of the capital
markets uh affects
our customers not green cell the company
itself
but obviously it's important that we
continue to support those
customers the first concern that i had
about the position of green sill the
company
as opposed to would covert have an
impact on the capital markets
and therefore impact our clients was
in december 2020 and in mid-december
2020
our german regulator proposed
a reduction plan with respect to
the amount of exposure that we held for
one of our customers
that was going to be impossible for us
to
comply with and
obviously that position was disclosed to
the investors we were doing a capital
raise
for equity for our own company at the
time to to fund our continued growth
we disclosed that to the investors and
that meant that the
capital raise which was otherwise um
supported by two of the largest banks in
the world
and was fully subscribed and looked set
to uh to close in late december or early
january
we obviously had to to pause that okay
as it happens in january mr chairman
uh the the often agreed
to a plan that we proposed which dealt
with that
immediate issue um uh
and then the the next event uh
was the the failure of our insurer to uh
to renew
which was in march but if we go back to
the pandemic you seem to be saying well
there were problems in the capital
markets but that were was for others to
worry about not so much greenfield at
that point although there is a
connection isn't there between
the impact that it has on your clients
and the stability of
your your own model of uh business
so but are you saying back at you know
when the pandemic first started and all
these problems kicked off that
you were really feeling pretty
comfortable about greenfield's position
and that is of course coincident with
when the lobbying really started from
mr cameron and yourself and others of
the treasury uh to get involved in the
ccff fund and so on
but are you set at that point there was
no need to sort of dash for cash or
or or to raise money at that point it
was all
pretty okay as far as you were concerned
as as it turns out
it was completely okay mr chairman but
what we didn't know
was what might happen in the future
nobody knew what was going to happen
next
and so we felt that it was prudent
given that greensol was not regulated
and therefore didn't have central bank
access
that the ccff facility was something
that
would be of utility to those of our
clients who
are eligible in their own right to be
able to
access the facility just as the bank of
england
had allowed back in the 2009-10
financial crisis so the fact that you
were there for seeking that funding
because you were concerned about
the future as i guessed almost every
business in the country would have been
at that point
it does suggest that you had a need to
go and raise that money to give you the
comfort
that you would ride out whatever was
ahead albeit
that was uncertain in itself would that
be
a fair way of putting it i think a
correct characterization is
we didn't know what was going to happen
next and we felt that having
for one of a better expression a
liquidity insurance policy
which the ccff provided to many
businesses
uh in in the country uh who were making
a material contribution to the
the country was a prudent thing for us
as a business to do
simply because nobody knew what was
going to happen next
okay so then the lobbying really starts
doesn't it and we've obviously had
the letters uh published today and i
think you you had access to those on a
confidential basis a little while
uh it goes you've had time to digest
them pretty intensive
uh lobbying particularly from david
cameron
um can you just explain to the committee
what kind of conversations you would
have had with mr cameron
uh around that lobbying in terms of why
the funding was necessary
and particularly on this point your
point about what it was necessary
because we had an uncertain future
and we needed to get uh some
arrangements in place to
cope with that and the potential
commercial threat that that posed
would you have discussed that with him
didn't they
so my discussions with mr cameron uh
centered on the facilities that
had been in place during the financial
crisis
how that facility worked and
the um the
mooted ccff facility
uh as a you would have noted in the the
letter that the governor
the bank of england wrote to you there
had actually been comments
uh from uh offices of the of the bank of
england
concerning the potential need for
supply chain finance support from the
central bank
so we talked about that and we talked
about
the fact that there genuinely was
uncertainty
about what was happening in the capital
markets um and whilst
i guess with the passing of time that
we've
perhaps faded into the mists of uh
history
but if you remember at the time it was
uh it was an extraordinary time where
liquidity
was in very very short supply um
and uh and so we were talking about what
impact that could have on our supply
chains
and that was also a concern to our
customers
recognizing that we were financing
millions of businesses and customers
in over 150 countries around the world
would it be a fair to say that the
reason given
during the lobbying as far as we know it
um
for these approaches to the treasury the
bank of england fca and so on was that
that you were going to be helpful as a
business to support smes
and supply chains and getting liquidity
and finance
out there rather than any mention of the
fact
as i think we've now established between
us that part of the reason for
trying to raise this money was also to
shore up against
a potential problem in the future
due to pandemic and perhaps other
factors
i think the same thing mr chairman
i think what our business was was to
deliver
low-cost real-time liquidity
to small businesses not only in britain
but around the world and that relied
on proper functioning capital markets
and they were not functioning properly
in march and april
2020 but that's that that's a great
story
and it may be a perfectly legitimate
valid story
for the treasury to motivate them to do
as as you were trying to
have them do but it is not one of the
big motivations here which you and david
cameron both
appreciated because you would have
discussed these things and you discussed
it with us now on this committee
that actually part of this push was to
get cash into the business because there
would have been
clear concern about the future of the
business at that point
given what was happening in the capital
markets as a consequence of the pandemic
and other factors
mr chairman i think it's important that
i make something very clear that
green seal itself and and indeed as the
chancellor put in his letter that he
wrote to you and the
chant and the governor of the bank of
england that
green cell at no time sought funding for
itself
well yes but the model the model
required did it not to sustain itself it
did need to have
funding the model needed to keep going
and having the funding coming would have
kept the model going
and it's the fact that you say that the
insurance
would pull that stopped the model
working and then the whole thing
fell apart our clients
needed that continued liquidity as has
always been the case and will always be
the case into the future
because these are real businesses in the
real economy
that are buying uh goods on a
on a daily basis okay
all right so thank you lex uh for that
i'm gonna go now to felicity please
uh good afternoon i want to follow up on
a few points that you've raised
with regard to your business model now
you've talked about the importance of
the credit insurance
and that is clear um i understand that
your insurers
actually gave you notice on september
the first
to take effect on march the first
um if i were in your shoes knowing the
importance of credit insurance to
your business i would have been doing
absolutely everything
from september onwards either
to have your existing credit insurer
tokyo marine
sign up again or to find your
replacement
because this is the critical cog in
the credit suisse asset management fund
did you do that
[Music]
ms buckin we absolutely
were confident in the fact that
our insurances would be renewed we did
business
with 28 insurers
through our brokers the the largest
insurance brokers in the world marsh
who managed those relationships for us
um and we worked intensively not only
with tokyo marine
but with all of our insurers as we did
every day
um to make sure that we had the capacity
to support our business
um it is a matter of fact that
in that we had been working
every week since that letter arrived to
actually
finalize a renewal with
tokyo marine and indeed one was drafted
between us and in an agreed form
before the end of the year and so
the the view that we had was that we
would either renew
with tokyo marine or we would renew with
others
recognizing the number of other insurers
that we worked with
and it's important also if i if i can
remind the committee that
for the credit insurance market covered
was an extraordinarily frightening time
when there was an expectation of very
very significant losses
uh indeed any governments including the
british government
announced support arrangements for
credit insurers
to try and help and encourage them to
continue
to provide capacity to the to the
markets
and so actually tokyo marine was not the
only insurer
to indicate that they would not renew
but in fact the others did renew driven
largely by concerns about regulation
and if i may miss [ __ ] it it strikes
me
that one of the key regulatory
shortcomings
shown by the failure of my firm and to
be clear i take responsibility for the
failure
but one of the key learnings is that the
credit insurance regulation structure
works in a counter-cyclical manner that
is
when the market turns down and the
probability of default of businesses
increase in order for the solvency
requirements of the insurer to be met
they must provide more capital because
the probability of default of the
businesses they've insured
goes up in in a crisis and that is what
happened during covert
so what happened was many insurers
needed either
more capital to provide the same amount
of cover or
they needed to cut cover in order to fit
within the limited amount of capital
that they had
and that seems to be an easy thing to to
have
okay but let me take you to the verdict
of the new south wales supreme court
and they did not accept your lawsuit
they threw it out
and they said that they were given no
evidence to show the talks took place
to renew the insurance other than a
letter dated february the 27th
2021 and can i also ask you to react to
that but
also as a supplementary given how
critical
this credit insurance was when did you
tell credit suisse asset management that
you did not think that you would be able
to get
credit insurance so let me answer the
second question
first if i made this bucket so
a number of our investors relied on
insurance
they received information concerning the
insurances that we held
directly from our broker marsh who
actually arranged the insurances
not us and and that information was
provided to our investors
on a real-time basis i.e every time
there was a change
they received an update so in many cases
that meant they were being updated on a
daily basis
so they knew the termination date
of the of the cover the same day
that i knew about the termination date
of the uh of the cover
because it was provided to me by the
same mechanism that it is to
to to to my investors and the new south
wales supreme court what's your reaction
to them
throwing out your lawsuit look we made a
difficult ask of the
supreme court and we made the decision
to do so
on the weekend before our policy expired
we had expected fully expected that the
policy would be renewed
or extended and when we found out
on friday night before it expired that
they would not be renewing
we had to very quickly put together an
injunction
where we sought an injunction to have
the policy temporarily extended
um and i think the court felt that given
the amount of money involved
and the limited amount of time they had
to consider the matter
um that it was difficult for them to
make that that judgment in a very short
period of time
but i i can't speak for what was in the
mind of the of the court but what i can
tell you
ms buckin is that we were working
day and night for basically every day
from when we received that letter on the
1st of september
to put the renewal in place with senior
management the most
let's move on because i'm conscious i've
got less than five minutes here
and the number of topics i want to
address in terms of the business model
now you've talked about how you were
lobbying treasury
in order to fund smes but it seems to me
that your business and the gupta group
business had a huge amount of
interdependence
can you just tell the committee how much
exposure you
had to the gupta group and what
percentage of your total exposure that
was uh and also with the reverse
how much of the gupta group funding did
you provide
with the greatest respect you can i am
not able to comment
uh about specific clients i've received
a directive from the administrator of
greensville capital
specifically on that topic as she's
undertaking
uh this and those matters are
confidential and indeed as you published
in your
materials today um there is a
correspondence there from the fca
indicating that they are conducting
their own inquiries so i'm really not in
a position to comment specifically
uh on the the uh any particular client
but the german regulator has clearly
raised concerns
about your dependence on that particular
client
and more correctly their dependence on
on us
yes absolutely mutually but i would say
to you ms buckin
it is absolutely the case as i said in
my opening comments
to uh to to your chair um that
we did have a concentration on certain
customers that was too high
and i'm responsible for that okay let's
move on in the interest of time
yes now i want to take you up on the
business model because
it's short-term receivables repackaged
with credit insurance until you
come across this very bizarre concept
of future receivables now in my mind
there's no such thing as future
receivables
you know there's a prospect of doing
business further out the line but that's
just the prospect
so if you're actually lending on this
basis
this is simply unsecured lending it's
unsecured lending
dressed up as receivables so that it can
go
into those funds
mr you are quite correct that if we had
not taken
security and funded future receivables
it would be
unsecured lending but in no case did we
provide
a facility that supported future
receivable financing that was not
secured on real assets as you say
like alone would be and indeed
i put it to you that future receivables
are widely used
as a form of financing think about it
the largest pub groups in the uk
finance themselves and their estate
using future receivables um most
football stadiums yes but can i
interrupt there's a big difference
between
having a history of cash flows
and projecting forward i understand here
that companies have said that they've
been asked about receivables
and they have done no business with you
uh i also uh see a quote from the
german regulator which says that they
were
unable to but sorry you were unable to
provide
evidence of the existence of receivables
in your balance sheet that you had
purchased from gfg alliance group
the maybe i can address the the german
point
uh first and then the uh your first
point second
so with respect to uh our bank
we booked assets that were real assets
uh they were booked according to
the advice and direction that we had
from our auditors
and from our legal advisors and indeed
we're actually subject to a review by
the deposit protection regulator
in germany um and
we we complied with that at all times
the buffon indicated to us that they
didn't agree with the classification
of those assets and and so
after a discussion with them we adjusted
the classification of those assets
but at no time was there a position
where the assets didn't exist
it was a question of classification
and so how did you classify them
we classified them as receivables and we
booked them
as exposures against the various
customers
of our clients and we'd insured
and bought insurance against the event
that those receivables didn't come into
existence plus took a comprehensive
security package
our regulator asked us to book that
exposure
as a single exposure against um uh
that customer in effect unsecured
landing
in in words as effectively a
loan to a precisely unsecured lending
yes
so can i pick the point in light of that
that that is not transparency here in
your business model
the whole concept of future receivables
is an effect
alone unsecured lending but it is being
dressed up
as supply chain finance
ms barkin every asset that we ever sold
was correctly described and that
information was
prepared and made available to our
investors to our auditors
and to our regulators and they had full
and complete information
at all times so i don't accept your your
assertion
i'm being told i'm out of time but just
one very quick question
when you were lobbying a treasury uh
to have supply chain finance approved
uh were other competitors of yours
lobbying
in the same way
i can't speak for what other companies
were doing but i
was aware that uh my competitors
also were concerned about market
conditions and were interested
uh in the possibility of central bank
support
um but i i can't speak for them i'm sure
you'll ask them to uh to give you
evidence
what was your reaction when treasury
said no
it seems as though they made the right
decision but what was your reaction
well uh my my reaction is uh is seen
from from the actions that we took
i was very keen to see that the
facility that the bank had put in place
the bank of england had put in place
during the financial crisis was able to
be made available again
um but ultimately as as you by the note
um
the treasury and the bank of england
decided not to do so
thank you thank you chad thanks very
much felicity brucinara please
thank you very much um mr greensell i've
got
a number of questions so um we'll try
and rattle through as quickly as
possible
um first i have some questions about the
lobbying process
can you just talk me through what
representations uh
you and david cameron made on your
behalf your company's behalf
to the chancellor or treasury officials
about green sales capital
greensville capitals application to the
coronavare's large business interruption
loan the seal bills
along the design of that scheme and the
criteria for accreditation
to the seal will scheme including um
in the meeting that took place on the
24th of april 2020 please
is ali neither mr cameron to my
knowledge
and certainly not i uh we did not make
any representations
to the with respect to the setup of the
cl bills program and the only
conversation i ever had with the
treasury
on that topic was a conversation which i
had
with the second permanent secretary of
the treasury where i informed him
after the scheme had been put in place
and it had been announced by the british
business bank
that we were now able to extend loans
under that facility
that it would be helpful given the level
of interest that we had seen
if we would be able to have the higher
uh limit of 200 million instead of 50
million
and the british business bank had
informed us that that was a decision
that only the treasury could make
and so i raised it up with the second
permanent secretary
and he subsequently wrote to me and said
that
he would need to see a request from the
british business bank
requesting him to do so and as you would
have seen in the correspondence from the
chancellor
no such request was ever forthcoming
from the british business bank
so it's it's really interesting because
um
the 27 days of the different days
mr cameron lobbied government ministers
and advisers 56
emails and whatsapps and counting i mean
i hope uh
and other text messages um and for those
of us who
understand how lobbying works um
the reality is you got what you wanted
in the end didn't you mr grinzill
400 million that's my understanding from
press reports
of the seal bills um loans to gfg
linked companies provided by your
company
so the lobbying did pay off even if it
albeit
through a different vehicle through the
british business bank
and you know which is overseen by biz
wouldn't you did you did actually get a
positive outcome right
as i say i didn't have any discussion
and you'll have to ask mr cameron
whether he did but i didn't have any
discussion with any government official
in the treasury or the bank of england
concerning the cl bill's
facility or our eligibility for it um
until after the british business bank um
had determined that
we were eligible right and and announced
it publicly
right uh so and and b did anyone have
any links with
the business department okay so can you
just confirm
the press reports that green seal loaned
a total of 400
billion million in the seal bills gfg
linked companies and it was split out
across eight loans of 50 million
and could you could you just confirm
that no i'm
as i mentioned earlier i'm afraid i'm
not permitted to
um to make any customers specific this
is about the past
and we're here to talk about the past
and what your involvement you've come
you've arrived in this committee
you've apologized for the 1000 jobs uh
lost in your own company
and and others related i think you owe
it to the british people to answer the
question mr greensell
i i'm afraid as i explained to
your your chair before i spoke
um i've had very clear instruction
from the administrator of green cell
and indeed from my legal advisors and
you have noted the letter from
the fca uh i'm simply not able to
comment
about specific customers but i i
will help you in any way i can with your
inquiries i think that people will infer
from your inability or reluctance
to come clean and be transparent on this
committee
on this parliamentary committee which
you claim to have respect for
that actually given the 15 million cap
it was
you know there was there was
that actually what you were doing was
you were deliberately
restructuring in order to take advantage
and you were actually doing something
that
was beyond the scope of what should have
happened that something improper went
on here which led to 100 million
of loans being provided
greensville capital was selected by the
british business bank
as being eligible to operate the scheme
the credit that we extended to our
customers
complied with our ordinary credit rules
and procedures which were scrutinized
by the british business bank each
facility that we provided
was reviewed by a top-tier london law
firm
and where there was any question about
the interpretation
of the british business bank rules we
actually had
that leading law firm directly
discuss the matter with the british
business bank in order to ensure
that it did comply with the rules so it
is my opinion
that every facility that we provided
complied
with british business bank rules
interesting
um and can you just talk me through how
many other
clb ils loans green seal
made or did you only
loan to gfg linked companies
we provided facilities to other
customers
um under the british business bank
facilities
so not only to any to a sort of
a single group for example and how many
of them
would you be able to say i wouldn't be
able to say
right and is that because again because
of the
the point you made earlier that's right
i'm
not permitted to talk to you about
customer confidential information
we're a financial institution it's
simply not something that i can discuss
uh in a in an open forum our clients
confidential information
so just going back to the lord miners
evidence session and obviously you've
addressed some
points that the chair has raised um
lord miners talked about the cost of
um told this committee that the total
cost uh
to the taxpayer from the green seal
scandal would amount to three to five
billion pounds including one billion
in direct costs and as you've heard
the chair um he quoted he was quoted in
in our committee as saying i left the
meeting traveling down in the left
thinking of myself this has
many elements of the ponzi s of a ponzi
scheme
you are you have come into this
committee today
and you have discredited his evidence
you've tried to discredit his evidence
um who should we believe lord miners or
you
who's lying who's telling who's not
telling us the truth here in this
committee
the public deserve to know the truth mr
greensell
certainly ms ali i have told the
committee the truth today
here are you saying lord mine has lied
to this committee
i'm telling you what i have told you is
the truth and it is supported
by written evidence right
so lord miners is not telling the truth
in ui is that what you're saying
what i've said is i've given a
correct account based on my knowledge
and recollection
and written evidence
the point is you've admitted to the
failure and the cost
yourself in jobs and the associated
losses to other companies
i have lord miners has talked about the
amount one billion pound direct costs
and it's in other
in other referenced by others as well
right and 3.5 billion indirect what do
you have to say to that
is he lying about that in your opinion
or is he telling the truth
and and is everybody else i mean it
seems like you're gaslighting here
you know you've blamed the insurance
company you're blaming lord miners
but the person the company that has cost
the taxpayer money
is your company and it's you
i don't recognize or know how broad
miners came up with the numbers that he
shared with this committee two weeks ago
and i haven't seen him publish a
breakdown of how he arrived at that
i certainly have noted that others have
quoted lord miners since then
but i haven't seen how he arrived at
that number
perhaps if we pause and and let's see if
we can work the number out together
one billion that's lord weiners
that number has been in the public
domain a very long time
so what how would you calculate it what
has been the loss to the taxpayer
there has been no loss to the taxpayer
is ellie
there has been no loss so once again
lord miners
is not telling the truth is not giving
the correct facts others who have
given evidence and not giving the
correct facts but you are you we are
expected to believe there's no loss and
you are telling the truth here
the total amount of we've just been
talking about the
cl bills facilities so the total quantum
of cl bills facilities
the greensville capital extended was 400
million pounds
the total amount of sea bills facilities
that we extended
was 18.5 million pounds c
seed bills and cl bills facilities are
guaranteed
to the extent of 80 of the amount of the
loan effect on a company
on the seal company and the knock-on
effect in terms of jobs and consequences
will amount to a greater deal of expense
to the taxpayer
missouri you asked me how the the
calculation around the billion direct
cost
was calculated what i'm trying to do is
help you to get to the fact
the facts here so the total amount of
guarantees
that uh from the british business bank
the guaranteed amount is 334 million
eight hundred thousand pounds
interesting so
about direct and indirect costs can i
can i just i'm gonna move
and you may once again you may not
answer this question
but i hope you will can you just talk us
through
when you started working with mr gupta
and his company and and when your
company started doing that
is that allowed are you allowed to
answer that question
and i think some of that is actually in
the public domain so i'm prepared to
comment on
uh the parts that are in the public
domain as well as i'm genuinely trying
to be helpful to you
i believe that i met mr gupta back in
2015 i was actually introduced to him
by an executive at euler hermes who's
one of the largest insurance companies
in the world
we did a very small amount of business
with mr gupta uh initially
um and that over time increased
that over time that that increased yes
that's correct
uh i i just have one more question in
relation to
insurance you talked about the insurance
company earlier
about the insurance facility not being
you know one of the reasons for the
collapse of green cell
um can you just can you just explain how
you come to that conclusion
uh furthermore a bit more about how you
come to the conclusion that your company
um why should the public believe that
that's the reason why your company
collapsed rather than the points that
fellow city
uh raised about the business model that
your company used
well i felicity has her um
her own opinion but uh you've asked me
my opinion
uh what we've done is we have taken
cash flows which we collect
from the accounting systems of our
clients
in real time and made that information
available
to investors so that they are able to
invest in the real economy
in a way that hadn't ever been able to
be done by anybody other than banks
before and we through doing that
we've been able to provide finance
to millions of businesses in over 150
countries
and those people did not do business
with me miss ali
because of our brand all because of our
marketing expense they did business with
us for one reason and one reason only
and that is
they got a better deal from us than they
could get
from their banks and so
actually what i would say is to those
millions of businesses and
employees who made use of our technology
they voted with their feet it is
absolutely correct we ultimately failed
miss ali
so there clearly was a flaw in our
business
but the fundamental truth is taking
real-time information
out of corporate accounting systems and
making
using that information to make credit
decisions
and make lower-cost credit available
completely electronic
electronically to small businesses and
consumers around the world
absolutely is the future but the way
that i did it
definitely has flaws and the insurance
value running out of time
but you what your conduct your company's
conduct
is hardly an advertisement for that kind
of credit
uh and small businesses to to small
businesses and in fact what we've seen
is a concentration of risk
what we've seen is that unsecure
unsecured loans in effect have been
provided
and you haven't helped businesses you've
actually
damaged the reputation of legitimate
supply chain finances
and to conclude in fact
in fact miners has a point doesn't he
it is it is a ponzi scheme it
is frankly its smacks of fraudulent
behavior
and it franks of the sort of stuff we
saw conducted by the likes of
the likes of made off in the financial
crisis
that's what it smacks off it doesn't
smack off a proper process where people
can get supply chain finance
that is reliable and credible
when i started green cell no member of
this committee
or indeed i think almost any institution
had heard of
supply chain finance now every major
financial institution in the world
offers it as a product rather like a
checking account to a corporate
that has meant that tens of millions of
businesses have benefited from that
yeah though mr greenfield isn't the
problem here
it's not about innovation around a
particular way to finance
isn't the problem here that you and
david cameron who pushed for this while
you're an advisor
in government and then you and david
cameron
stood to benefit from that process the
idea might have been a good one
but there is a clear conflict of
interest here
you didn't do you know your idea might
have been valuable
to the world of finance but what you
created
ultimately and the conduct of lobbying
in the way that that had happened using
a former prime minister
frankly bringing that position into
disrepute
to benefit to profit is where the
problem lies and going so far
that actually many would argue you and
mr cameron
lost sight was what i lost sight of what
the right what was
appropriate behavior and appropriate
action in terms of providing supply
chain finance
is ali the beneficiaries of
green cell and the business model that
we developed
which has now been copied by thousands
of financial institutions around the
world
has not been a great boon to financial
institutions
the reason it has has grown as it has is
because it's helped
tens of millions of businesses that's
not the point here the point is
and and many of our experts who get the
experts who gave evidence recently
talked about where the positives are
to supply chain finance the question is
whether what you created
and what you were selling was actually
proper
supply chain finance or a ponzi scheme
and i i can
i i state to you that your scheme
was something quite different from a
proper appropriate
supply chain finance process that
protects the public interest and in fact
what your company did is lose taxpayer
billions potentially indirectly and
certainly
a few hundred million up to a billion of
public money
i'm going to stop there because i know
others have other questions thank you
right i think it's probably only fair
let's if you did have anything to
say to that to say it you may not do in
which case you're hesitating that's fine
um i will go on to siobhan please
thank you mr greensell are you a
fraudster
no mr connor i am not okay
because i'm a layperson and i've looked
up the definition of fraud
it's an act or an instance of deception
an
artifice by which the right or interest
of another
is injured a dishonest trick
again as a lay person it seems to me
that this is precisely what your
financial model
of prospective receivables is nothing
more than a trick
lending against transactions that have
never happened
may never happen and with companies that
don't even know they're involved in the
transaction
and then selling it on as a low-risk
bond
it's pretend it's an imagine imaginary
thing
so how is that not fraud
mr mcdonough the business that we
undertook
was properly described
all of our investors understood exactly
what it was that they were purchasing
in any investment there is risk
but what we did is we took the history
and the current activity of our clients
that history and data enabled us
to see what was going to happen in the
future
and allow businesses to be able to
access credit we didn't just do that for
the private sector we also did it
for the public sector and indeed
it was done by the public sector here in
britain
before greensville capital was even
funding
uh government-related supply chains so
no i don't accept
your statement and but i do recognize
that any financial asset comes with risk
and because we considered that our
reputation
would be harmed if our investors were to
ever lose money
we spent tens of millions of pounds
every year
purchasing insurance to protect against
an event
where there was a loss that arose
and we took significant security
packages to support that
position so we felt
and i continue to believe that the
business that we undertook
was a business that helped
the broader economy and frankly is in
line with
forms of financing that have been
conducted here in
for periods of time long before
greensville capital even started as a
firm
i gave the example of hubs here in
britain how much were you paying for
your insurance you were paying one
percent
on unsecured loans which were a risk of
over 10
how did you believe that the insurance
you were paying actually
met the risk
so where the goods had been
delivered and approved
and we did extend unsecured credit
and and in the history of our firm
there was a failure uh
one that was in the press was a british
listed company
nmc healthcare ours
it had supply chain programs provided to
it
by half a dozen banks i believe of which
our institution was one and
our institution was the only one to my
knowledge
that was able to through our technology
systems and processes
to correctly identify fraudulent or
potentially fraudulent transactions
and exclude them whereas my
understanding is
other financial institutions did fund
those that company ultimately
went into bankruptcy in the papers
mr greensteal in the papers signed by
you
uh to the administrators you say
that step one in your business was
the custom and i quote the customer
obligator is issued an invoice by the
supplier
in the normal course of business however
this only happened about half the time
and most of your revenue related to
times when
no invoice was involved isn't this
description deceptive
our business was all about financing
receivables
and future receivables but no other
business does future receivables they at
least expect that there's an inventory
in half of your cases there was no
inventory
and there was no invoice there was no
evidence of
any activity or business whatsoever
the condition of our facilities ms
mcdonough is
that they must
do business with the customer they must
have the history to support that
and the data to support that and we take
a secured interest
where it is a future receivable so where
the goods have not yet been delivered
and indeed to protect our investors we
purchased insurance
to ensure that in the event that there
was an issue
of any description including fraud
and the insurance would be effective and
if i can come back to my
nmc health example our investors there
even though that company actually did
apparently or allegedly commit fraud and
we
excluded the fraudulent uh transactions
our investors were paid under our
insurance policies
so they were protected that's why we
spent the money on the clarity
the clarity i'm not accusing anybody of
fraud
other than yourself in 50 of cases
there was no inventory there was no
invoice and the insurance that you paid
cost substantially less than the risk
you held
you have much more experience and
knowledge
than me you knew that that insurance
would never cost the risk
that you was actually wrapped up in your
business
i i disagree with your assessment um
miss mcdonough
in the company's house submission you
described green sill as a supply chain
finance company
but this represents only 10 of your
business as i think felicity has already
said
with 90 representing unsecured
loans to high-risk borrowers
are you trying to deceive creditors
about your company's true business model
so i'm not deceiving investors around
the business model of our company we
never have
and we went to great lengths to make
sure that not only
did our investors have full information
about what they invested in um but
indeed
that in fact we also in many cases
provided insurance
to protect against the event that
actually there was a default
and that insurance had been proven in
many instances
over the years to be effective and to
protect the investors
the government's coronavirus support
programs were introduced
at the same time as you were trying to
reduce your exposure to gfg alliance
mr greensault was it your intention to
shift as much of that exposure
onto the government books and ultimately
the british taxpayer
using a full former prime minister to
aid your case
is moved on right if not able to comment
on specific clients as i mentioned
earlier
and earlier in your evidence you
suggested that the public sector
didn't lose out from your dealings but
in the list of creditors uh that you
that you submitted from your firm
includes islington council only a few
miles
from westminster which is currently owed
a hundred thousand pounds by your fa by
your firm
don't you think you should pay them back
we owe with respect to
council tax on the offices that that we
have
in uh in central london and that's where
that
that arises and i'm extremely sorry that
that's occurred
okay thank you chair
thanks very much uh javon i'm going to
go to angela please
thank you and i want uh mr greensell to
talk about this concept of
prospective receivables
rather than future receivables which
seems to be even
more um detached
from actual business that is going
on and be almost entirely speculative
how much of your business actually
that you wrote actually was prospective
receivables
and angela the percentage of our
business that was prospective in
receivables was zero i've never heard of
the concept i read about it in the
financial times
if you were to look at the documentation
relating to any of our facilities
you would never see those words appear
so yeah
just make just to make absolutely
certain
um that i've got you correctly here mr
greensell
you you're saying that you never
um financed a deal for
any uh invoicing
supply chain invoicing that hadn't
actually happened
but might be in some future period
expected to happen in other words a
future receivable or a prospective
receivable
but we we did provide facilities with
respect to future receivables
um i'm not familiar with your
description of a prospective
receivable but as i was explaining
to the previous member
we provided secured facilities not
unsecured facilities um that
covered future receivables and the only
exception in fact to that
dame angela is in the case of her
majesty's government
and the nhs pharmacy early payment
scheme that we funded those were future
receivables
and there we did not take security
that program has been running since
2013.
we took over together with tolya funding
that in 2018
and that program which is funding future
receivables
allowed pharmacists to reduce their cost
of capital
according to the pwc cost of service
inquiry
which was undertaken in 2011 it enabled
the reduction of the cost of capital
that was paid to pharmacies so at
taxpayer expense
pharmacies were reimbursed for their
cost of capital
which was previously 12.3 percent that
was the average was 12.3 percent
in fact for small pharmacies it was over
17 percent
that was being reimbursed um
i think there are going to be some
questions about that um
subsequently but i know that you you
said originally that you'd never heard
of the concept of
future receipt prospective receivables i
said prospective receivables is not a
concept in any of our documents
let's get back rather than uh worry
about a phrase
let me rephrase the original question
then how much of your business was
actually future receivables
of our total flow so last year we
funded uh 143 billion us dollars worth
of receivables
and the future receivable component of
that i don't know the exact percentage
off the top of my head i will provide
that to you as a written answer
uh post this but it would have been
less than 20 of our activity of the
receivables
that would be very helpful and and and
perhaps in that letter you'd also
let us know whether that percentage had
gone up over time as
as your business approached its final
at the numeral which obviously nobody
knew about that that would also be
helpful so i can get a sense of
whether i could becoming more relaxed
perhaps i could provide you the 2017
2018 2019
2020 numbers so that you're able to see
that dame angela
that would be very helpful now the other
issue about this particular
um future receivables um concept
uh that's worried me while i've been
looking at this
is that the ft has published
clear evidence of invoices referring to
firms
which now say they never traded
uh with gupta or gfg alliance or
or you and yet you seem to have
securitized
some of those invoices so that rather
hints that there's some fraud somewhere
doesn't it
damn angela as you'd appreciate i'm not
able to comment on
specific clients and certainly
ones where there's the possibility of an
investigation
into that um what i can tell you of
course
uh is that at no point would we
or my firm have uh engaged in financing
uh receivables which
we uh knew to be fraudulent
of course not but uh what due diligence
did you do
especially in those groups that if i
could say
uh you were you were sort of had a
symbiotic relationship with
such as gfg it's worth noting
um dame angela that gfg was not our
biggest customer
um we had bigger customers than than gfg
that we provided more funding to
and in all of our clients the core of
our business
was accessing directly and generally in
real time
their accounting systems to to extract
from them
both current and historical
trading information to enable us to
make informed and real-time credit
decisions
around our ability to support the supply
chains in which
in which they operate and i understand
um that it's possible to do that by
going into systems if the trade has
actually happened
and the invoices exist because there's
actually been a transfer
but if we're talking about prospective
receivables
how did you check that there was
no fraud there because it just seems so
so
convenient that you can you can um
package up and securitize something that
uh
one of your clients says has happened uh
with the with the future flow of of uh
payments attached so that you can then
sell that
as an asset when in fact it looks like
the situation has arisen that uh these
were all
fictional uh and so what you were
actually selling into the credits was
bonds
and and marketing to investors were
things that were
just unsecured lending and wishful
thinking
angela as i've said before um with the
exception of our uk
government future receivable program the
other future receivable programs were
secured
not unsecured um and benefited from
insurance but let's use
the uk government future receivable
program to answer your question
so there what we do
i don't want to talk about the uk
government futures receivable program i
want to talk about
these securitized investments that you
sold into um
but these things had actually happened
and they weren't just the figment
of somebody's imagination in in say the
gupta industries
so we securitized the
uk government future receivable assets
just as we did the others
and what we did is we took
real time and historical information
which we used in order to make
projections as to what would happen
in the future and if we were to use
the pharmacy example here in the uk
for many years that operated where we
built an algorithm together with
the department of health that predicted
what the value would be of each
prescription
that was filled here in the uk
and ultimately even predicted how many
prescriptions
would be filled in each pharmacy here in
the uk
and that program because we were able to
provide that financing ultimately at
less than one percent per annum
compared with the weighted average cost
before the pwc
determined and the government was
reimbursing of 11.3
per annum that saved the taxpayer
100 million pounds or more than 100
million pounds
every year well that is the saving
that comes from using technology
capturing information historical and
expected future activity
from accounting systems of clients saved
the taxpayer
over 100 million pounds a year mr
greensteal i'm i'm talking about what's
uh gone wrong and why your company
collapsed and why there are now
huge amounts of losses um not least to
those that invested in the credits reese
bonds i'm just going to ask you again
what kind of due diligence was done
when you securitized these these uh
prospective receivables from the gfg
group because it looks increasingly and
you don't have to comment on this but it
looks increasingly like
the case that you were securitizing
invoices that didn't really exist on
flows of money that weren't
due now that you know um
has meant that the credit suisse
investors have lost large amounts of
money
that lots and lots of people have lost
large amounts of money
because they've invested in bonds and
and assets
so-called assets which you created and
securitized
which were actually unsecured and high
risk
not low risk as they were marketed by
you
so we did the diligence that we
conducted
was all outlined in the security
documentation
that investors purchased they did so
with full knowledge
we did it based on the data that we
collected from our clients
and but they made a decision just as we
did
um in when we purchased those assets as
a principle for ourselves
that we trusted those clients and that
the data that we were collecting
and the verification that supported that
was sufficient
and it may well be the case that
we learn lessons that say that more
should have been done by us
and but that's uh something for the
future but i would emphasize to you that
so far
no one has made a loss that is the
reason we purchased insurance to protect
investors against that
potential catastrophic event but are you
saying that the insurance is the
security rather than the physical assets
that you're meant to be selling
not at all and wherever as i said before
dame angela and i'm afraid you've
contradicted me on a number of occasions
but i'll
correct you one more time um where we
did future receivable programs
other than for the british government to
my knowledge
all of them were secured against
real assets to support those facilities
can you tell me how you can finance at
one percent
and pay insurance premium and all of the
other costs that go with securitization
uh sorry you've said that we financed it
one percent i
presume you're referring to the uk
government supply chain program that i
was referring to
yeah uh the the margins we we actually
charged a lot less than one percent in
the case of the
uh the uk program uh and
it's the the insurance that we pay is
based on the probability of default of
our customers
the probability that the national health
service is going to default is
quite remote so the cost of that
insurance is quite low and our investors
are prepared to buy that asset
at a level that reflects that uh of that
risk
but it is true we made a very modest uh
revenue on providing the solutions that
we did
to the british government indeed in
aggregate we made a loss
um providing these solutions uh to the
uh to the british government
but the beneficiary of that with the
taxpayer
in the savings of over 100 million
pounds a year and of the many businesses
that supplied
the uh the national health service who
were able to access
credit at less than one percent per
annum
now the person that wrote your insurance
for
tokyo marine was dismissed for writing
too much
insurance and taking too much risk
um what and and
and
isn't that what caused your business to
collapse in the end i can't comment on
um an employee relationship with uh
within
an insurance company um but
what i can say and i did say at the
outset uh is that
we had an over-reliance on
insurance generally and we purchased too
much of our insurance from
one particular insurer even though we
did buy cover
from 28 different insurers we did too
much of our business
with one insurer dame angela and that's
definitely a learning
and i take responsibility for that and
what kind of
um security did you have on some of
these securitized
assets that you sold into credit suisse
because i've read in various places that
although these are meant to be
short-term
assets that you backed them up with very
very long-term
illiquid um security
buildings and things like that correct
so we were financing the working capital
of the business
but in the event that there was a
default we had security
and the strongest form of security is
absolutely to take security over
bricks and mortar um and inventory
uh receivables and other assets of a
business
just one final question and that is
gupta was actually
was he on your board or he had some
shares in the company at some stage what
was going on there
mr gupta was never on the board of uh of
my company
yes there was a very short period of
time
where we at that time we're doing a
small amount of business
with him uh he bought a small stake in
our firm
and then subsequently we decided to do
significantly more business with him
and my board and i judged that it wasn't
appropriate
to be having him as a shareholder
and provide more than a de minimis
amount of facilities to him
and so he sold those shares completely
and those transactions were affected uh
within
a couple of months of him becoming a
shareholder and then uh and then selling
out
and he did not make a profit uh on that
sale he sold the shares for the same
price that he purchased them
and did you do the same thing with
softbank given that softbank also
um financed uh green sill
and then um seemed to have borrowed
extensively from the credit suisse
so none of our the two large
institutional shareholders that
we have um borrowed money from
greensville capital i think what you
might be referring to dame angela
uh is that um
our we provided facilities to
companies in which uh softbank
vision fund was a minority was a
minority equity investor in
other companies and we provided certain
facilities to those other
companies that's correct thank you
thanks angela to alison please
thank you chair um mr grimsel in the
2019
annual report for green cell capital it
lists concentration on certain customers
key employees and suppliers
as one of your key risks can you tell us
um
did you feel you were carrying a
concentration risk at any point
i'm sorry ma'am would you mind
just saying that question again please
sure in greensville capitals 2019
annual report it lists concentration on
certain customers
key employees and suppliers as one of
the key risks
um in the annual report yes given all
that sam
that has occurred since then did you
feel at that point you were carrying a
concentration risk
at any point before or after
our annual report is accurate and
it is the case that in in a small
company
when you start your first company the
first customer you do business with by
definition is a big concentration risk
the first partner that you have who
provides you with services
is a big concentration risk um when
griefs for capital failed we were a
little over nine years old
and so as we grew it is absolutely the
case
that we had concentrations that were
unacceptably high and we worked hard to
bring those down
but as i said in my opening remarks it
is the case
that concentrations we had both on
insurance and clients
were too high um and were
the principal contributing factor to the
failure of my company which is
to my very significant regret and
in identifying those risks and
appreciating those risks which she
clearly did what action did you take
we built a very material
risk function compliance function
and and also continued to build out our
legal function
we changed the way our risk approval
processes worked so we created a
separate credit committee i was removed
from the credit and risk approval
processes of the
of the firm such that any members of our
board
um were unable to participate in the the
risk approval processes
um additionally we as we grew we aim to
further diversify our
our business which we did do but
clearly not enough when covert comes
along
and you know significantly disrupts um
the insurance world and indeed that of a
number of our clients
and at what point did you do those alarm
bells starting for you
that perhaps your survival had been come
too linked to any one of your customers
and there was too much risk in one place
certainly it was apparent that that was
the case in december last year when
the bathroom wrote to us and proposed
a reduction plan that was unachievable
for us to do
and potentially had they implemented it
and to be clear they did not order us to
make that reduction plan they proposed
it to us
but had they implemented it that would
have likely been
catastrophic as it turns out um they
ultimately agreed a different plan with
us
which we were able to to work to and we
expected to be able to meet
um so it was clear to me um in december
last year
that that concentration was um
potentially a risk to
to the entire firm um but we had been
working diligently to reduce our
exposure prior to that date
so it can't come as a huge surprise to
you
uh as in
in december is that what you mean yes
yes they're coming to you with this
decision that can't have come out of the
blue entirely then
surely certainly it did come out of the
blue in the sense that
we actually um had agreed to
and basically been following a
concentration reduction plan
up to that point um but the buffer then
proposed or rather
suggested that they were going to
propose a much more onerous
uh reduction plan which we would not
have been able to comply with and would
have
potentially put the put our firm at risk
but i want to emphasize they ultimately
did not implement that plan
um but out of transparency and
completeness to the committee i wanted
to be
to be to be open with you about the fact
that that was the point
at which i became concerned and it was
that point that then triggered
us bringing in restructuring advisors
to advise us at the end of december on
the 31st of december last year
we appointed advisors to assist us
around um managing that risk and making
sure that we were going to be able to
uh to um carry on in serving all of our
customers
okay i mean it seems a bit odd to me
given how you described to
um miss mcdonough they could have
crystal ball like qualities you had
within your business for predicting what
was going to happen in different
businesses that you didn't see this
gaping big hole in your own
with the benefit of hindsight it seems
that you are right
okay you talked about um
one of the answers about your your
business model being copied by other
organizations around the world
given what's unfolded here should that
worry is
i think as i mentioned when i was
addressing your chair
um i think that one of the real lessons
from the failure of
my firm and the impact that it's had on
you know the 1200 employees that
that we had um is that a heavy reliance
on trade credit insurance uh is
dangerous
and i would urge you and the committee
to consider
the manner in which that is regulated
because it is fundamentally
counter-cyclical in its behavior and
there is a long list of
companies not financial institutions
like mine but there is a long list of
companies here in the uk
that have been put out of business by
credit insurers
making uh changes which are driven by
um uh the the turn of the economy um
which of course is what happened
um when when uh covert broke out earlier
this year sorry uh last year and
and obviously had an unprecedented
impact on uh on our economy
you talked we've talked a bit about the
kind of exposure and having a
one kind of big company um one customer
rather
which is quite big compared to the
others that you had
what's the kind of balance that there
was on that and
and was this was the service that you're
providing to that one large customer
different
were you retreating your other clients
sure i want to emphasize that
the customer that you all think is my
largest customer was not
um i'm not allowed to say
but the the british company that you
keep talking about was not our largest
customer
in terms of the assets that we funded so
the error that we made
and the importance in the business model
was to have a diversity of capital
available to support every one of our
customers
um and we had two concentrated a
mechanism of funding
for some of those larger customers so in
fact
our largest customer had very diverse
committed funding from banks to support
it
was very very stable that is what we
should have done
more generally across our business um
but there
were a handful of customers um where
we were much more reliant on credit
insurance
um and fewer investors and that
created a concentration risk which
ultimately
undid the dream that an awful lot of
people had
um and the good that we had done around
the world
to put a percentage perhaps on
the amount of your business that went
through these large companies compared
to your small clients what would that be
uh i've
i guess i'm going to have to rephrase
your question to
to to accurately answer it so if you
think about
um our clients they have
thousands of customers and suppliers so
essentially
the party that we contract with tends to
be the pinch point
in between the purchases of goods and
services and the sale of
of those on on to others and
so in terms of those pinch point
customers
we had um between two and 300
of those customers in total and
in terms of the kind of suppliers and
the
customers to uh and the consumers that
supported those businesses on both sides
that amounted to more than 10 million
okay and i wanted to
ask a bit more um about the issue you
mentioned about insurers
and you mentioned i think a one large
insured and i think 28 smaller
ones is that figure that you'd said it
was it was 28 in total
yeah okay and one of those
disproportionately larger and
again could you give us a bit more of a
description of what that looks like um
yes i'm
very reluctant to to mislead you in the
committee so could i ask to provide in
writing to you afterwards
um what the actual breakdown was so that
i don't
kind of accidentally mislead you but um
it was a
material double-digit percentage um with
respect to
tokyo marine okay because i think it
would be useful for us to understand
um exactly what these risks look like to
the company exactly what the waiting is
um on where these things lie um so we
can get a better idea of just how much
risk there was
um in particular areas and because
obviously this has gone badly wrong this
is a complete mess the house of cards
has fallen to the ground um
and taking a lot of other things with it
so i think understanding the balance of
where those risks were
and would be quite useful for us um as
well
and lastly i was i was curious just on
another point that you'd made about
a the assets you were securing against
and if you give any examples of what
perhaps those physical assets were
yes so those as as i mentioned uh um
when answering answering um dame
angela's questions
uh those assets um ranged from
real estate uh to
vehicles to inventory receivables
intellectual property um
kind of credits and licenses of of
various natures
cash and indeed personal guarantees in
some cases
of of principles of of the business
and often case uh security over the
actual
shares themselves and the companies that
uh that we provided these facilities to
okay thank you i think that's all the
questions i had too
thank you thank you alison and steve
please
thank you chair i refer to my registered
shareholding in
glint pay and i do so because i'm going
to ask you about green sill as a fintech
business
now mr green silk i can't help noticing
that in the midst of what must be a
personal disaster for you for
a former prime minister for the
employees you had and everybody else
involved in the miss this disaster
if i may say so your face seemed to
light up a little as you started to
explain that the
kind of business you were conducting was
the future and the others are following
your suit and i wanted to just give you
the opportunity to tell us a little bit
about that what was it that was the new
thing that you were doing
and how did that make you a fintech
business certainly
so the business that that we undertook
recognized that the extension of credit
to small businesses in particular but
also to consumers in the economy is
largely predicated
on information that is and when i
started the the firm or indeed actually
when i started working in supply chain
finance in the uh in the in the mid
uh decade of the start of the 2000s
that information was trapped inside
the accounting ledgers of businesses and
governments
had that information been made available
on a real-time basis
to banks or to financial investors
that would enable credit to be extended
both electronically
and much more cheaply because the risk
was less it's just that
banks simply didn't know what was tied
up
inside a company's records for example
the fact that
they knew they were going to purchase
some goods in the future or that they'd
already received those goods and they
were going to pay for them
at some point or that an employee had
already worked a certain
number of hours and therefore was
already owed a certain amount of money
by taking that information out of
corporates and governments
and making that available to the
financial sector
we were able to reduce the frictional
costs of delivering capital to
uh to other people and and uh to do that
i i did note um in your committee a
couple of weeks ago
um i think we were sort of somewhat
described as luddites
um i suspect that the more than 600
people who
worked in my business in technology and
support functions a great many of them
here in the northwest of england um
would have been um
pretty shell-shocked to have heard that
but frankly it would be impossible
to do that at the scale that we were
doing it and we were extending credit
on an average day in the order of half a
billion dollars
it simply would not be possible to do
that
kind of with pens and paper it had to be
based on uh on technology mr barker
speaker but don't worry about it but
this is what i apologize
it's all right don't worry about it it's
not the end of the world in all the
circumstances
so the point is you're using technology
to get inside people's
accounting ledgers to understand what's
going on and to reduce the
the cost to providing credit and i think
you've articulated that really well
you mentioned employees and their wages
i think that's this app called earned is
that right
yes sir and is that still in business
i'm afraid i haven't quite caught up
that uh earned was uh was sold
um and was was purchased
by uh by wage stream which is a british
company
but to be clear that service was offered
before my business entered this space
um however the difference was uh that
that
service um had a a unit charge
to it typically a charge of a pound or
two
for the employee to be able to access
their pay early
yeah because we were already integrated
to the accounting systems of many um
kind of private sector and indeed some
public sector entities
and we were able to easily use that
information to effectively
allow employees to get access to the
same thing um
and so we were happy to provide that
service
at no charge to to employees largely
because it was
using the existing infrastructure that
we had built recognizing we made you
know millions of payments
and we already had that infrastructure
so tell tell us a bit about that
infrastructure to what extent was it
proprietary to what extent did it use
ai machine learning all those good
things certainly
so like uh um all businesses we
invested heavily in continuing to uh to
grow our technology so it would be fair
to say that when we started the business
in 2011
the technology of our business was
largely excel spreadsheets um
but as our business grew we very quickly
uh had to uh to adopt um more and
and better technology we were on the
fourth generation of our technology
um at the time that uh that our company
went into administration
which was substantially reliant on
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to uh to deliver the solutions
that we did
um but uh and and so
um but the the infrastructure of what we
undertook
um was somewhat unique in the in the
marketplace and you know we were
certainly for example
um amongst the biggest or the largest
non-bank issuer
of bonds in the market so taking
millions of payments every day crunching
them together and delivering them onto
investors
so the reason i ask about this is that
david cameron i think explained that the
reason he wanted to get involved was
because you're exciting fintech now as a
software engineer i can fully understand
that you start a business with excel and
make your way towards
machine learning um but i understand
that at some point in this she was using
something called taulia systems was
so was this tell us where tullia or how
you pronounce it where did that fit in
in your technology journey
certainly it's pronounced talia and and
uh
um so i guess we're even on this we are
even here we go
at least on this square um so
uh we we worked with a a bunch of
different partners
actually um and uh talia were specific
specialists in working within an sap
environment which is one of the largest
erp providers um which
which you'll understand and we also
worked directly with oracle
we worked directly with a number of
other software firms i think we
we had more than 10 partnerships with
with different companies that we
partnered with
and in order to have various
capabilities
that we needed to uh to use um of course
we then unify those
um with our own proprietary technology
um and
uh deliver them on like most uh
technology firms we use some stuff under
license and some of the stuff that we we
develop on a proprietary basis in a
nutshell what were you using machine
learning to do
certainly um well let's since i we're
going to talk about the national health
service um the the learning there is
to predict at an individual pharmacy
level
what drugs are going to be prescribed in
each individual pharmacy in england
in the next two months and allowing
those pharmacies
to uh to be able to access cash against
that prediction
so this is why i'm forgive me because i
could ask you about the technology all
day and no doubt your engineers as well
but this is really the point of what i'm
getting at because on the one hand
you're
still enthusiastic clearly about
articulating your vision and what you
were doing
but the central point here is the
honesty of the claims being made by the
firm and the honesty of the firm's
business there's no escaping that
and i think this goes back to the heart
of the questions which were being asked
earlier this
uh this rather semantic discussion about
prospective versus future receivables
so when you talk about those
prescriptions being made
just to play it back make sure i've
understood correctly you're saying that
machine learning was used to predict
what prescriptions would be made in the
future and to use that
info information in order to provide
credit it's the two data points that
we were having to predict um
was the number of prescriptions that
would be fulfilled
in each individual pharmacy yes and
the reimbursement value of each one of
those prescriptions
those those are the two data points
effectively that determined
um how much a pharmacy would receive in
reimbursement
um from the department of health so i
can see there's the complexity here
because what you
do i can see why people have used the
word perspective because those
prescriptions had not actually been made
and yet you were providing uh credit on
the basis that they would be yes
correct okay based on based on the
historical
performance of the the historical um
activity that had taken place in each
one of those pharmacies in the country
okay so this i think really is the heart
of the matter so when some people look
at that kind of business model and
accuse you
or it of being a fraudulent business
model
what would you say to them that makes it
clear that it wasn't a fraud because i
think that's the heart of what you're
being held to account for here
certainly we were using data
inside corporate systems to allow
the customers or suppliers that they
have to be able to
for us to be able to unlock capital
using that
information and
using the example here in the in the uk
in the uh
um in the pharmacy scheme that meant
that we were extending
on average um
at any point in time just under 300
million pounds
on a consistent basis uh to pharmacies
that wouldn't have been available to
them otherwise and almost all of that
went to small pharmacies whose cost of
capital was being reimbursed to them
by the government prior to the scheme
being put in place
at a double-digit cost so that saving
accrued to the taxpayers
using that technology now
i have to tell you i'm quite
uncomfortable with this degree of
securitization even securitization of
people's wages
even as a free marketer i don't think
anybody on the committee would say i'm
quite possibly the most free market
member of the committee but i'm still
even so rather concerned by the degree
of securitization you're engaging here
in here in order to drive down the cost
of credit
what is it about it that caused that
glimmer of excitement
in your in your face earlier about this
kind of model why is it that we should
why would you tell us that we should be
wanting to support this kind of business
in the future
i wasn't asked to come and give evidence
today to tell you
why you should support this well i'm out
i'm asking you now because you told us
earlier
that this is the with some pride if i
may say so that this was the direction
of travel
in which the world was headed and you
for the record you're nodding so that in
a sense i i'm really asked because i'm
concerned now that this is a big bigger
problem for the future if other firms
end up with similar business models
failing to spot their
absolute weakest link in the on the
point in your case of the insurance
my goodness what a mess we could get
into if this is where the world is going
so i'm really asking you to make to to
in a sense to to tell all the
journalists watching all the
moms and dads all the policy makers and
regulators
why why should they be concerned to
support this kind of business
i think the value has been to reduce
the cost of capital in the economy
very significantly uh over the uh the
last decade
um and with technology
we will get even better at being able to
predict
what's going to happen in the future the
key learning has to be
where does the risk for that failure sit
and in the case of my firm mr baker
because i relied on other investors
so our own proprietary balance sheet
was insufficient to do this all by
ourselves
that meant that if an insurance company
withdrew
some of my third party liquidity was no
longer available
so i think the key question comes down
to the durability
of the capital that's supporting the
businesses
and the durability of that capital can
either come
from that capital being within the
control of the party that's providing
the solution or the durability could
perhaps come
from having greater certainty and
longevity around the insurance
that's being provided to
those those those businesses such as
such as my own would you agree with me
that there's a major risk here that in
using
ai and machine learning to rapidly
expand credit on a huge scale
that the risks of such a business model
indeed the risks inherent in any kind of
use like this of that kind of technology
could very very quickly expand beyond
our capacity to regulate or
contain those risks at all and i think
that's why
you're asking questions of me so that
you can make sure that you can
understand those risks well i certainly
have
learned something today thank you very
much mr baker
thanks steve and harriet please
thank you chair and um i want to
park back to the time when your business
was valued at 3.5 billion dollars with
the
capital injection that you received from
softbank
and i just want to ask you what you
thought about that valuation at the time
my view of the valuation at the time was
that it was consistent
with the valuation
of the business when our previous
institutional investor
um had uh had invested uh about a year
before
um how many times earnings was it twenty
times
twenty twenty two earnings so it was
twenty times one year forward
you you've mentioned uh quite a few
times
during your evidence that uh you
obviously
have a great pride in the service you
were providing to
uh pharmacies in the uk um
can you quantify for the committee how
much
value you think came from the fact that
you were doing
work um that had the sort of imprimatur
of the uk government on it including
of course uh an advisory relationship
with the former prime minister
when you ask the question um is paul
when about
the value do you mean the kind of
financial value or do you mean more
broadly than that
i i want to try and get a sense of
whether you think
that that 3.5 billion dollar valuation
had in it um some kind of premium for
the fact that you
were obviously well embedded with the uk
government and you had a former prime
minister as one of your advisors
sure so uh the multiple that that
softbank vision fund invested at
was roughly identical to
pretty much identical to the evaluation
that the previous investment about a
year before by general atlantic had been
and general atlantic's investment took
place
before we had started funding any uk
government
programs so i i definitely think it was
helpful um but i don't think that it was
definitive of the valuation given that
the multiple remained
uh remain the same um and relative to
current market multiples
uh uh 20 times forward
would actually be relatively low for a
company that
is in the financial technology space
okay
thank you um turning to this uh sort of
what looks to
someone like myself has quite a sort of
circular relationship in terms of
some of the financing you had softbank
investing as a capital investor
um were there cases of funds uh or firms
rather
that were both funding themselves
through your supply chain
finance product and then also
investing either capital or investing in
the funds themselves
so this report in 2019 from bloomberg
that said that vodafone was putting
invoices into a green seal-sponsored
supply chain finance fund
and also participating as an investor
and then vodafone's treasurer coming to
work as your
your cfo um that that's not an example
of what i described
actually i'm mistaken i had forgotten
that one instance so
uh that that is is the case um
uh but of course it's a not an investor
in our equity
and i thought that was the question that
you were asking me ms baldwin
um was um whether people were invested
in the equity of greensville capital
and we were then financing the same
company and the answer to that
remains no in the case that you've just
cited me from vodafone
they were investing in a supply chain
finance
fund and we were also
funding their supply chains and however
to be clear at no time was vodafone
an equity investor in greenville capital
yeah i asked about equity investor or
um supply chain finance funds i'm sorry
if that's not clear but you're saying
there was one
one example there was only one example
and that was vodafone
i would say there were no examples where
they were equity holders but
a supply chain someone who is getting
supply chain finance from your funds and
also
investing in the funds you'll appreciate
that those funds
none of the funds were green sale funds
um and so they're not my clients
and so i don't know who were invested
and you would need to ask
the managers of those funds if they were
prepared to
reach client confidence to share that
obviously i can confirm to you
the position with respect to vodafone
because it has been in the public domain
okay so um you can't rule out that that
was happening more extensively than just
in the vodafone example then
uh to the extent that it did happen it
would be
a tiny like you know less than
0.01 of the activity of our our business
so
it was not a core part of our business
model uh um as certain sport
and would it have been a potential
conflict of interest that would have
been noted in your policies and
something that you actively managed or
that the board was aware of
it's difficult to see how that would be
a conflict of interest
ms baldwin said no actually um we didn't
because
if uh if if you think about it if
someone invests in a fund
those funds will hold multiple assets
they are managed by a third-party
fiduciary manager not not by green sale
that fiduciary makes investment
decisions
based on the rules of the fund
and if a corporation or a financial
institution wishes to invest in that
fund
those funds are only funds that are open
to professional investors
um and so those professional investors
would make their own determination so
no that was not something that we had a
policy on we did however
have a policy with respect to providing
facilities
um to entities that were related to our
shareholders
um so i you couldn't be a shareholder
and
we lend to you without there being a
very specific process
that had to go through the highest level
in our board to be uh to be approved
so turning again to the softbank example
and they were clearly an
equity investor they also it is reported
invested in credit suisse funds but
you're saying that was a
separate organization to yours and you
you couldn't really get um involved in
that particular conflict of interest
but you were also receiving a loan
directly
from uh softbank as i understand it
um did you ever feel uncomfortable with
all these different dependencies and
different relationships that you had
with softbank
i should be clear with you that the loan
uh
such as it is that is on green sales
balance sheet with
with softbank is a convertible loan
that is essentially equity and
it automatically converts into equity
upon receiving regulatory approval
green sale capital isn't actually an
australian company
and in australia foreign investors need
approval to be able to invest
and because we owned 100 of a bank in
germany
it also required german regulatory
approval
so that loan automatically converted
into equity
when those approvals were granted and
that loan
carried an interest rate of zero and it
had a 10-year term
so in effect it was equity so i just
want to be clear there
that it was it was you know for all
intents and purposes it was equity
but you had mentioned earlier that uh mr
gupta sold his shares
when he wanted to benefit from the the
supply chain finance
but you're saying that this was a
different case with softbank because
although they were an inves
equity investment investor with you
directly
you were not at the time aware that they
were also investing in some of the
credit suisse funds
i was aware that uh that they were
investing in those funds
yes but there was a meaningful gap in
space and time between that so their
investments into i think their last
investment into integrins equity
investment into integrins with capital
was
um i think in october 2019 i believe
um and uh i think as reported in the
in the press um their investments into
the credit suisse funds
um was um i think in the second quarter
of uh
of 2020. but help me out in terms of
what distinction you make between that
example
and the example you gave earlier with mr
gupta's equity investment
where the board decided that he should
sell his shares yeah
yeah so but i think if you think about
the
metrics there um the
here softbank is a shareholder in
greenseal
and uh softbank was also an investor in
a credit suisse fund
did two separate kind of investments
um greensville wasn't lending money
to softbank so the difference was the
gupta example was
mr gupta was a client of our firm and
and
to be fair there was that conflict for a
very short period of time which is why
we
ultimately as our firm got bigger and we
decided that wasn't too
uh prudent for us um we decided you
shouldn't have
um without very special approvals
shareholders that uh that we lent money
to
okay and can you talk a little bit more
about the conflict of interest that came
about from
uh softbank being an equity investor in
your firm
and uh for example you getting involved
in providing financing to
some of the uh companies that were in
their vision fund
were you lent upon to do that no we were
not meant upon to
to do that um but absolutely um there
were different additional controls
uh required there uh so for example um
i stepped down from so when our company
was
young i sat on all of the committees in
the in the company obviously
as we got bigger that was no longer
appropriate
and in the case of both the credit
committee and the risk committee of the
firm
i stepped down from from those
committees and nor was any other board
member
a member of the credit committee the
risk committee of course did have
members of the board sit on it but i was
not a member
those controls were there to make sure
that
credit was extended um was done so
purely on a stand-alone basis taking
account of the
of the veracity of the the the company
in question
and not based on kind of uh who
one of their minority shareholders might
have been so
it was just complete coincidence that so
many of the
vision fund uh investments were
also customers of yours
we were introduced to those companies by
softbank
um so there was no sort of coincidence
um but it is uh but we obviously did
business with as i as i mentioned
earlier
um hundreds of of companies
uh and uh softbank vision fund companies
amount to a very small handful of those
fewer than fewer than ten
but i mean the ft has reported for
example that you only started
financing uh the car company fair
after they'd already become you know
become quite evident that they had
uh difficulties the chief executive had
announced plans to cut 40
of the workforce and had resigned for
example um
did you feel lent upon by softbank in
that example
no i did not feel meant to bond by
softbank um and
the that particular facility
um which has has been repaid in full um
uh did not result in any loss to uh
to our company and was was was repaid uh
a hundred percent
so i guess you don't feel that
throughout this
uh this period of
incredible expansion in terms of the
business that you were doing that you
uh came across any uh business that
represented in what anything written by
your firm that was
represented a conflict of interest in
any way
in any business there's going to be
conflicts what i would say to you is
that
we felt that we manage those conflicts
by keeping the decision making separate
um so i'm not saying to you there's no
conflict whatsoever there obviously is
some conflict
between a minority shareholder and a
company that we lend to
and a shareholder in our company the
management of that
to try and mitigate the risk of that
conflict
is about separation but also
when we sold those investments
to to our customers uh to our investors
that bought those
assets they were aware of that
information
and those assets came protected with
insurance
to protect them against an event of
default but they had the full
information
to make that determination so i think
there's
several layers of of uh consideration
there but i'm not saying to you
there is no conflict what i'm saying is
we aim to manage it
and we gave disclosure and
if you were a regulator
because to me this sounds all quite
quite worrying that there was a bit of
an arm's length but it you know
doesn't really pass the spell the smell
test to me now
if you were a regulator what uh change
would you
make in terms of the regulations well
certainly in the case of um credit
suisse which which you've alluded to
that was reported in the press
has has also been reported in the press
credit suisse had an independent review
conducted of that um and
they proposed certain changes to the to
the rules of the fund
but they continued to uh to to to
provide the fund
in the case of my business um i think
the um as as we got bigger what we aim
to do
and what we would have needed to
continue doing
um is to have further controls
to separate um the ability of
shareholders to influence the extension
of
of credit but i am satisfied that um we
did a a fair job of that um throughout
this process
especially given that there was the
disclosure to
to our our end investors
but what i'm hearing you say is that you
do acknowledge
that your shareholders did influence the
extension of credit
no what i said is that there is a
conflict of interest there
and that is why we separated our
shareholders from the decision-making
process around the extension of credit
i'll let uh those listening
decide uh what uh what they think uh
it should be done uh and no doubt we
will comment on this in our report thank
you chair
thank you harriet uh emma please
thank you chair i was a little surprised
at the beginning mr greensteal to hear
you
discredit the evidence given by lord
miners and i do hope he has given the
right of reply
to this uh to this session to actually
clarify
some of the points you made but i want
to start with some pretty quick
questions if that's okay has greensville
ever been under investigation
by the fca i appreciate that it would be
a criminal offense
to comment on that can you clarify
whether you've been
under investigation by the fca
the answer to that is the same okay so
back in 2018
which is obviously prior to the in in
what's happening now
when the fca were looking into the gm e
f
g a m scandal were they looking into
green still
as well i'm afraid the answer is the
same yeah
so you can't comment on an fca
investigation that happened
in 2018 which is not
what we're talking about right now
i'm happy to advise on whether i am
allowed to do that
and if i am i'm happy to give you a
written response on that
okay okay thank you um
and also can you just confirm obviously
about naming
recipients whether you had eight lots of
50 million pound loans
sorry eight lots of 50 million pound
lines i'm sorry
yeah in the answer you didn't quite
answer the questions to my colleague
rashinara before
about whether or not you cut you said
because again you weren't able to give
evidence whether or not how many loans
you actually had
fee bills loans
right no i'm i'm not able to uh to
comment specifically on the uh the
facilities that we've extended
right so i'm not asking for the names of
the recipients i'm just asking you to
clarify how many loans you've had
um and i would need to take advice on
whether i'm able to uh to answer that
question
um and i'm happy to give you an answer
afterwards if i am allowed to
all right let's try another one then um
did the government officials advisers or
ministers play any role in introducing
you to mr gupta
no okay can you explain how and when mr
gupta started working with greensville
capital yes i did answer that question a
little earlier
um on this hardy but just to to answer
you again
uh i was introduced to mr gupta in uh i
believe it was in 2015
uh by an executive at uh at an insurance
company
okay and following all the evidence
you've given so far
i'm just going to ask you this as a
straight question do you think it's
appropriate
that a firm like yours was not regulated
by either the bank of england or the
financial conduct authority
well we didn't take deposits from
consumers in the united kingdom um
and we uh the only
product that we provided in the united
kingdom
was business lending um and
business lending of which supply chain
financing
forms a small subset business lending is
generally not regulated um
so that's obviously a decision for this
committee and for the government as to
what's
what should be regulated or not um
uh i have said to you you asked me to
give you my
honest assessment of why i think that my
firm failed
and i think that the reason that my firm
failed um is
because of our um uh over-reliance
on a single insurer um who
withdrew capacity i believe because of
um
covert related events and so
that's my view as to why we failed
but i would say to you that you did own
a a bank um and
and therefore we we dealt with a
prudential regulator in the in the
context of uh of of that as well
um we do think
that as we got bigger we expected to be
ever more regulated and we
we welcomed um that position
but our core business is not a regulated
activity in britain nor is it in
very many countries around the world nor
is business credit generally
okay and now bearing in mind you
obviously discredited the evidence of
love miners earlier but
lord miner said uh in the evidence he
gave to us and i'm quoting that mr green
said clearly decided that he did not
want his business to be regulated
by anyone is that what attracted you to
the business model you adopted
the lack of regulation not at all
the business that we
undertake undertalk um is no
better or worse for for want of
regulation um
and you'll appreciate that um much of
our activities
took place where we worked with
counterparties that
were highly regulated and therefore we
were required to
operate to their standards um and
and so therefore i don't see that there
was
any particular advantage uh granted to
our firm
by virtue of our regulatory position so
for example um
much of the business that we undertook
of extending
supply chain finance uh certainly in in
europe
was conducted through our german bank
and so therefore
fully regulated okay now i understand
you can't tell
or answer the question that up to
whether or not you've been investigated
by the fca either now or back in 2018
but i wonder mr greenstone would you
expect a business who was under
uh investigation by the fca to declare
that to the treasury and to the british
business bank before doing business with
them
i don't uh have a
view on that we would be complying we
would comply at all times with
whatever the the legal requirements were
okay
in in its written evidence to the
committee the bank of england notes that
the first indication that the bank had a
potential weakness at greensville was in
march 2020. this suggested a possible
weakness in controls rather than
crystallized financial difficulties as a
quote from the bank were you ever made
aware of weakness in
weaknesses in your controls and if so
what was the weaknesses and what was
your corrective action yes
obviously i read the same letter that
you did
ms hardy uh i that the bank of england
has not provided me with
the particulars of what it was that they
were referring to so i can own these
speculators to what i think they were
referring to
but it is my sense that they are
i'm probably referring to discussions
that were taking place with the deposit
protection
authority in germany around the
concentration of one of our particular
customers
and the plan that we'd agreed with them
to
progressively bring that into
a lower level of concentration but to be
honest with you i don't know because the
bank of england
didn't disclose to me what uh what the
nature of their correspondence was
and did you not sort of think to us
considering the bank of england writing
about your company
uh well i was only provided with these
letters
um kind of a day or two ago so uh
no i didn't think that i would get an
answer from the governor of the bank of
england
uh in uh in in a matter of a day or two
i have just with you giving evidence to
a committee in public i just
thought you might want to clarify what
the bank of england is writing about
your company but okay
um how much contact did you have with
regulators
well the the chief executive's letter
um lists the interactions that that we
we had with them um we aimed to be
proactive in talking to them about what
we did and
what we were looking to develop for
example
before we launched the earned product we
went and talked to the
the fca about uh about that product as
well um
uh we obviously had extensive
discussions with uh
um with the
regulators in in germany over over a
long period because of our ownership of
of greensville bank um um so
i guess you know we had a dialogue with
them um i
don't think that our level of dialogue
with uh the british
regulator was anything like what a bank
in britain would have with
with uh with the regulator um but i
guess that's because we didn't take
deposits here in the uk and we didn't
extend um credit that we were charging
interest on to
consumers okay and did the regulators
take more interest
in your business following the events
surrounding the gam fund
in 2019 i'm sorry could you ask that
question again please miss harley
of course did the regulators seem to
take more interest
in your business following the events
surrounding the gam fund
in 2019 not that i noticed
okay so there was no additional interest
after gm hey is that what you're saying
in your business not that i noticed no
okay why did you use the appointed
representative feature for greenfield
capital securities limited
rather than seeking to get the
regulatory permission yourself
sure you'll appreciate that critical
capital was a
a nine-year-old firm we grew
uh over over a period of time we
worked with quite a number of
broker-dealers um
so third parties who are very
significant financial institutions who
are major broker-dealers
uh um on an international basis um so
here in london
and uh and abroad um but over time
uh we determined that it would be
sensible for us to have
our own regulatory capability
but we expected that to be a pretty
modest portion of
our overall activities and
[Music]
we therefore considered given our size
that it made sense for us to
uh to make use of the uh the appointed
representative structure which
as the the uh the letter from the chief
executive of the fca points out is
is used by forty thousand businesses um
in the uk
i'm sure your question to me really is
is there a lesson to be learned from
that
um i think there are two comments i
would uh would make to that ms hardy one
is
that we fully planned
and expected to um move towards
being um so doing away with the
appointed representative and bringing
that
completely in-house um and indeed uh we
had discussions at a board level uh
around that over the
six months at the back end of last year
and but i think if you were looking to
make changes
and you were asking me that question i
would say
it may well be a volume threshold limit
um where the appointed representative
scheme
should not be used um and obviously
although we started
out being incredibly small um in the uh
appointed representative
program that grew over time as our
business grew
and it may well be that uh there ought
to be a threshold at which that's no
longer acceptable
okay now earlier on you discredited the
evidence again from miners which was
around the cost to the taxpayer
being of five uh billion you said it
wouldn't be one billion either i think
you used
the phrase if i can remember correctly
around 400 a mere
400 million costs to the taxpayer but
you'll be aware
that um earlier on the fe released a
piece which was titled
how lex green still helped sow the seeds
of the carillon
crisis now you say that you weren't
involved in the caribbean crisis in
providing supply chain
finance get a company and i end up
pronouncing this wrong so you can
obviously correct me
called texture which sold since to
assault to oracle
used green still as a supply chain
finance and they sold it
the debt to carillion isn't it the case
that you have not only a hand in the
green seal disaster which is going to
cost the taxpayer billions
but also the korean disaster which ended
up costing around seven
billion pounds of debt i'm
i'm sorry miss harley i'm did you say
that
would you mind reading me the the quote
because that doesn't
make any sense to me involvement in the
caribbean
crisis in providing supply chain finance
a company called texture which was since
sold to oracle used green sill
as a supply chain finance and then sold
it to carillion
so i'm asking what the link is between
carillion and the debt that ended up
costing the taxpayer
and your company green cell
texture was purchased by oracle
yes used not by carillon
used green still as a supply chain
finance
and then sold it to carillion
no that is not correct
so sorry so texture which was so
tropical did not use green still as a
supply chain finance that didn't happen
oracle through texura did use greenself
for providing supply chain finance
um what did not happen is texura was not
sold
to corellia and textura did not sell
a supply chain finance program or
capability
to um carillon
right so the journalist has got that
wrong it would say that the journalist
has
okay okay that's fine so you had no hand
in the carillon
uh crisis whatsoever through using green
sales supply chain finance
absolutely not well that's one thing you
can cross off your list then that's good
okay thanks very much and there are
press reports that you struggle to find
a new auditor to replace staffordy
champions is this true
so our group auditor was
nexia international um
of which safari champions is the uk
member
uh next year international um according
to their website is the eighth largest
audit firm in the world
um we did business with
nexia at the request of
our our auditors um i apologize our
regulator in
germany who specified that they wished
us
to continue to use the same auditor at
our bank
as had been in place before we purchased
um
the other bank um and that meant that we
actually needed to switch
because prior to that our auditors were
grand fulton
um and then when we purchased our bank
in 2014
the one of the conditions of that from
uh from one of the regulators in germany
was that they required us to continue to
use the bank's auditor
and grant thornton would not
uh have that be the case they they uh
and so therefore um we had to use the
international group of which the german
auditor which is called
abner stoltz um formed a a member of
which was a part of the
nexia group um but to emphasize
greenville capital is an australian
company um and so the principal auditor
is
nexia international of which suffrage
champis was their uk partner and they
audited
our uk operating entity thank you
how easy do you think it was to audit
greenfield
and where did auditors have to pay
particular attention and what did they
often ask you about
i i'm not an auditor so i don't know
whether auditing our firm was
kind of any easier or more difficult
than auditing any other
um financial institution uh i i would
say to you that
kind of the volume of transactions that
we financed is a significant number
because they are
uh in effect lots of relatively small
receivables that
uh that we purchase um but they're
centralized uh
into a couple of um country
jurisdictions
but of course we did business in many
countries around the world
and and no doubt that creates a level of
uh of complexity
okay final question what was
the news that greensville
representatives said that they were
quote very pleased to hear from the
treasury in an exchange of emails on the
24th of april
2020.
i don't immediately know what it was
that um
was that particular news so i'm afraid i
don't know the answer to that question
off the top of my head but
uh i'd be happy to consult my notes and
and see what that
what that was and provide you with a a
written answer ms hardy
okay so just to clarify you're going to
be writing to us if you can to let us
know whether
green still has been under investigation
by the fca
and to clarify what it was that excited
greenfield representatives so much
from the treasury on the 24th of april
correct
thank you thank you chair thank you emma
and good to go anthony please uh thank
you
chair and uh i refer everyone to my
members of
registers interest uh i've been an
investor in
and on the board of and then advised to
a range of large range of financial
technology companies one of which hasty
is the same line of businesses earned
and i used to work at morgan stanley as
well but i don't think we ever
overlapped or met there um the my first
question i just want to follow up the
point that uh emma hardy was asking
about that
were you saying it's against the law for
you to say whether you have been
investigated by the fca in the past
and if so which law is that
um i i would say mr brown that uh i
don't want to um break the law and so
what i've said is that i will provide
you with a written answer if
if i am allowed to do that i have not
brought a
solicitor with me to uh
i thought you're a lawyer yourself i'm
not an expert on
uk regulatory matters well yeah i i
as a former chief secretary banks
association i'm really people are
quite open about whether they've been
investigated by the fca in the past so i
might be wrong but i certainly don't
think there's anything
in which case i will i will provide you
with a written answer to your question
so the two things i'm interested in
finding out my questions to you are
really the regulatory lessons uh from
this and you've touched on a bit of that
but then also
uh about uh the potential
youth or abuse of public authority um on
the on the regulatory
lessons uh as you said supply chain
finance isn't regulated it's
business to business lending it's uh you
know it's a contract civil contract
between two businesses
um you did point suggest there are
aspects of your operation that should
where regulation should change like the
appointed
representative regime you said there
should be a volume threshold and that
sort of makes sense when you get a
certain size you can't use that
anymore um are there any other aspects
of the operation that you think
regulators should look at we are
speaking to the fca
uh tomorrow i think that
um it is the case as
uh indeed miner said that it is
important to think about
the asset liability mix um of
kind of all financial institutions and
particularly uh
ones uh such as mine and uh and so
i think he was right to ask those those
questions um
and uh i would suggest that uh
there definitely is a question around um
financial technology companies um making
sure
and having robust controls around their
asset liability matching
um in in our case um the kind of
the reality was the assets and
liabilities matched but only
with respect to part of our business
only so long as insurance was there
so kind of regular asset liability rules
would say
you were fine but in fact actually
um not necessarily take account of the
that critical ingredient of uh of the
insurance so
it seems to me there may well be some
merit in in giving that further
consideration mr brown
and what would be that america's
normally the the attitude of the
regulators is
as you said it's it's consumer
protection and deposit protection and
you you didn't make deposits and
your consumers as i understand it didn't
lose that directly but what would be the
because if we're going to make
recommendations about changes to
regulation because you understand
exactly what the benefit would be of
doing that or and how widely you would
do it yep
mr brown i'm i'm not a uh an expert here
i i guess i wanted to just
call your attention to i that that
clearly
is a consideration the way that
kind of insurance fits into asset
liability management
i'm not sure what the appropriate
formulation uh
would be i would say with respect to
insurance the
the principal question that i would kind
of ask
you to perhaps consider um is that
inherent
kind of counter cyclicality of insurance
and and i'm sure you have seen this in
your previous
capacities writ large where credit
insurers withdraw
credit insurance at exactly the moment
when it is most needed
um in the economy because of the way
that the the solvency
regulations work and that seems to me to
be a
an inherent flaw and the the failure of
my business is
is in part evidence of that uh that
therefore it seems to me
okay i don't want to ask about your
public sector work you you
um how you obviously you had
a lot of dealings with uh governments
and uh clients of government how
important was that to your
business model the public sector versus
your private sector work
certainly um from a revenue perspective
the public sector business was uh was
negligible
um from a volume perspective um it was
um moderately uh important it accounted
for
a couple of percent of our volume
um on an annual basis i would i would
approximate
um but i think the to us
the the value of the activity that we
undertook
uh in government was if i
can be maybe tell you a truth that
is uncomfortable for people in
government to hear and the truth is
that government tends to be less
efficient
than the private sector and so when one
is
working to make savings um it's easier
to prove
larger savings um in a public sector
uh environment and when you are a
business
that doesn't have a brand that everybody
knows and therefore people are looking
at actual value cases where real value
has been
uh has been captured um that's certainly
something that's
very kind of evident uh in
in the business that we did for the
government and as i cited to you the
very very significant ongoing savings um
in the procurement of drugs in this
country as a consequence of
of of that solution so it is that as a
proof case
um which the private sector then looks
to um when they're considering what what
they're doing
uh in in terms of um improving
uh their own uh supply chains
i mean i completely agree with you about
the inefficiency of inefficiency of
government and the ability
in certain circumstances for private
sectors to uh help
increasing efficiency just on the um
supply chain finance with the
uh with the pharmacies which you just
mentioned that the presumably if the
uh if the government did pay uh its
bills on time within say 10 working days
uh then there would be no room for any
supply chain finance i'm very glad that
you've raised that point
um it is of course government policy to
pay suppliers within
10 days uh yeah but that's the point and
i was in charge of the payment terms
uh in the greater london authority and
foresters now
yes and and so uh on the face of it
it's crazy to to implement supply chain
finance it's crazy to use private sector
money which on the face of it ought to
be more expensive than um where the
government can borrow money
um to do this and it's crazy to have an
intermediary in the mix
who's presumably taking some profit out
and therefore
is effectively a tax and
the truth unfortunately mr brown is is
somewhat different
the the truth is that uh
unlike the private sector government
doesn't have the capacity to approve its
invoices
very very promptly and so as a
consequence of that
there is a delay even though you want to
pay within 10 days
there's a there is often a delay and
that delay if one looks at what the
private sector does
that delay can be solved using analytics
machine learning algorithms um to
accelerate that process
um but um so one private sector can
bring that
learning which is part of what we did
the second is
paying suppliers faster to
previously government paid in 30 days
and and then it was changed to 10 days
arguably
why not pay them in one day well that's
actually a cost to the taxpayer
because the ex-checker has to borrow
that money to provide it
what the private sector does with the
supply chain solutions that uh that are
provided
is that allows the people who benefit
from it
that is the suppliers to government if
they want to get paid faster
they can pay for it rather than the
taxpayer paying for it because the truth
is the majority
of expenditure the government has with
suppliers
is not with small businesses but as with
massive multinationals and do you really
want
to be subsidizing their cost of capital
so
have the private sector provide it and
have those that want to use it
take advantage of it and the the third
point then and the final point that i
would make
is that in fact even if you did devolve
to government departments the authority
to
uh to pay using private sector
technology and just use their own
cash the reality is that that capital
is charged out at a much higher cost
by departments than the private sector
provides
and the reason for that as i'm sure
you're very aware is that although
treasury
can borrow money very cheaply it
provides it to departments at
and i'm not going to use the right word
i'm sorry but effectively a weighted
average cost of capital that where
overall the government borrows money
whereas if you're advancing money to a
supplier to government
on 30 days faster than they were getting
paid before
then i as a financial institution and
borrowing money for 30 days
taking government risk that's a lot
cheaper to fund
than 10-year weighted average cost of
borrowing for
for the exchequer which it passes
through to departments and
i use the tenure as an example but so
there's a very big difference
between the two and so have the private
sector benefit from it
have them pay for it but have it
actually be cheaper than the government
department would actually be able to do
that based on
the cost of capital the treasury
provides that was the rationale
for uh for doing what we did
do you explain exactly what your role at
number 10 was when you're your number
10.
so i was brought into the cabinet office
um in in 2012
and the as you'll appreciate
it was in the wreckage post the
financial crisis where there was a real
focus on
um helping small businesses and
help improve their access to credit so
that
the uh the challenge that was was
leveled to me was
are there ways that i could provide
advice based on my experiences
um that that would enable government to
make
interventions that helped
small businesses to um to get cheaper
access to
credit or better access to to credit um
so that was the
the reason that uh that i was brought in
and and
uh i provided those services um to the
government
uh at no cost um i was simply trying to
share my
uh my my uh my experience um and uh and
give something back
and this is before you set up green cell
no
i had set up greek greenstall as an
australian company and so greensol was
set up in late 2011
and i was engaged by the cabinet office
in february 2012. and so did you use
your position in the cabinet office
uh as you say uh to influence any
uh commercial contracts with government
to gain access to people who might be
interested in signing contracts with
greenfield
absolutely not the first government
related business that green sale capital
uh ever won and funded against was in
july
2018. um
and greenville capital didn't have any
customers here in the united kingdom um
until 2015. so
you left the cabinet office actually i
was still a crown representative
uh at that time
what do they do i didn't create the
scheme so i
know i'll give you my potted version of
it mr brown
um but i think the intent behind the uh
the program
was to bring private sector um expertise
and to assist with commercial
negotiations with
suppliers to government to ensure that
government could get the best possible
deal
and so you were a crown representative
while trying to get
contracts for green seal with the
government no
no no sir um what i said is that the
first
time that greensville capital had even a
customer
in britain not nothing to do with the
british government but a a a customer in
britain the first time it did
um was uh was in uh was in 2015.
and that and you were no longer a crown
representative at that point i was a
crown representative at that point
but that company had nothing to do with
the government and by the time you had a
first government contract you were no
longer a current
representative it was more than two
years after i had ceased to be a crown
representative right
because there was a uh there was an
article uh in the times
uh in august 27th march 2021 uh noted
confusion about how a report ended up on
the
uh then prime minister david cameron's
desk advocating supply chain finance for
pharmacies
uh and his confusion over how that
report actually ended up in the prime
minister's
uh uh red box i'm sure you saw it uh did
you have any involvement with the
writing of that report
unfortunately the uh the times didn't
provide me with a copy of
uh the report that they're referring to
and
given that i'm uh ceased having access
to government
email systems um
more than five years ago i'm not able to
to see the exact report or the
correspondence that related to that
but what i can say to you is that um
it would not have been possible that a
report that i could have written
would have ended up in the prime
minister's box i'm sure mr brown you're
aware of the processes and controls that
sit around that
it would simply be impossible for an
advisor to write a report that
that uh ended up in the prime minister's
box um unless it had been reviewed by
by others and determined that it was
worthy
by jeremy hayward another former who you
met at morgan stanley
that's correct so he as in it's correct
i met him at morgan stanley uh mr brown
yeah but
he could have put a document in the
prime minister's
box and could have got it from you
i can't speculate as to uh as as to that
mr brown
but i i i guess that's possible he was
the cabinet secretary
but are you and you don't know whether
you don't know whether this times report
is true though about whether a report
you wrote ended up in the red box
about supply chain fine that's four
pharmacies which then the prime minister
then adopted as a policy
uh i wrote a number of papers that it's
my belief
ended up uh in uh in the prime
minister's red box um
and the pharmacy scheme uh
was a scheme that was announced uh
by the prime minister um at the round
table that was held i think it was in
october
2012 i think if my memory serves me
correctly
so that formed part of the group of
announcements that were made by number
10
uh in conjunction with that that
roundtable
okay i would love to ask you more
questions but i'm afraid i i've run out
of time but thank you very much
thank you mr browning thanks anthony and
going back to angela
please thank you uh very much um
why did you have david cameron as an
adviser
to your company uh mr greensell
what was his role certainly
so my board and i uh decided to
approach david cameron to prospectively
become a uh
an advisor to us and actually in the
event of
we we had recently lost um
a procurement process with a significant
blue chip company
where although we had the better
technology um
that uh that that company had taken the
view that they didn't recognize our
brand
they didn't know who i was and so um
i guess we were thinking about um how
we could um grow and expand
um the brand awareness of ourselves as a
as a firm okay and prior to him joining
the company how much contact had you had
with him particularly in your time in
government
uh i met him a couple of times
in the time that uh that i worked for
the cabinet office
but you you would say then you didn't
really come across him
very much i didn't really know him
okay uh what is his
job description and role would you say i
mean we've seen advisor but can you
enlighten us a bit more about the job
that he's been doing for you
so mr cameron uh advised us
with respect to the growth of our
business
um you know in the time period that uh
that mr cameron was an advisor to our
firm
we added more than 100 countries
uh to the number of countries that we
purchased
receivables from from customers in and
of course that analysis and geopolitical
thinking was something that
that mr cameron assisted us with mr
cameron also
met with many of our uh current
uh and prospective customers and indeed
partners that uh that we did business
with
and uh and generally um
assisted us with uh with the uh the
growth of of our firm
okay so clearly a a successful
relationship
from your point of view how was he
employed was he
a paye employee or did you pay him
um per hour or or what
he was a payee employee he was a paye
employee
okay was he employed by the uk part of
the company or by a foreign part of the
company
the uk okay and would it so
was he even though he wasn't a board
member i'm assuming he wasn't a board
member
that's correct he was not a director of
the company okay did he attend
board meetings he had a standing
invitation to attend
and did he do that regularly yes
okay um what were the value of the share
options
well certainly the percentage of share
options that he was
allocated
about is is it that or is it different
you'll appreciate damn and angela that
i'm not allowed to kind of give you the
exact numbers but i can tell you that it
was less than one percent
less than one percent more than half a
percent
i'm not going to haggle with you at all
i i would say it's less than the one
percent that's been uh
that's been banded around in the press
okay
is there any reason why you can't tell
us what that is that doesn't seem to be
any reason i mean
lots of people think money's quite a
quite a nice thing
are you embarrassed about talking about
money
no i'm i'm very careful though about
respecting the confidence of
people who are employees of the company
and i understand that mr cameron's
giving evidence to you in two days time
dame angela so perhaps it would be most
optimal for you to
ask that question directly of him well i
had noticed that we've got that coming
up so don't worry i'm sure that
some questions along those lines will
will come from
one of us maybe not me who knows before
he agreed to approach the chancellor
about the ccf scheme
um did you give him any briefing notes
to let him know what you it it was you
wanted him to
lobby for on your behalf
so mr cameron and i definitely talked
about the matter before he
uh he spoke with
anybody in bank of england or in
in treasury i believe that he
had sight of the submission that we had
made
to the bank of england when they would
prior to the implementation of the ccff
i'm sure you've perused the material
that the governor of the bank of england
provided we
we heard what the governor the then
governor had said
where he had said that he thought that
there would be need for a
bank of england support for supply
chains um and so we
wrote him so mr cameron had seen that
and then we
made once the the scheme was announced
dame angela
um we made an application to the bank of
england and mr cameron
um would have had visibility uh to that
application
i don't recall that he would have been
provided with anything
above and beyond that which we had
provided and therefore is now in the
public domain okay so there's nothing
else to publish about
about that as far as you can tell not
not to my regulation dan angelo
and how much use did mr cameron make of
your private
jets the four that you your company had
uh that would be for mystic cameron to
uh to comment on dame angelo
oh come on that's not a secret surely
i mean it's a cost for your company
again we've seen these photographs of
him all over the place talking to people
he must have made some use of your
private jets did
did he have one to hand or did he
generally go with you what so what was
the
what was the the way that you organized
the use of these private jets in the
company
sure the private aircraft that the
company had were for
the use of executives of the company
and david and i apologize mr cameron and
i did travel
together uh on uh company aircraft
and um that was certainly an efficient
way of getting around
so presumably there's there's records of
all of that
absolutely there are records of every
aircraft usage that
ever took place okay uh and
why uh was mr cameron uh meeting
with your insurers in australia because
there was a meeting there that you had
with insurers
that's correct he did um so
mr cameron was in australia uh
speaking at um
a uh an event out there um forgive me i
was you're going to want to know who
that
is uh so he was uh in australia on a
uh a speaking tour where he was speaking
for the
um at um at the invitation of the united
israel
appeal um and given that he was in
australia
uh already he
provided one morning of his time while
he was there
and during that time he met with a group
of
our current and prospective customers
and also met with the one of only two
australian insurance companies that we
worked with
uh he met with the chief executive and a
number of other
board directors of uh that insurance
company together with
our broker marsh um and
that was consistent with what he had
done in meeting with
other insurance companies who who
partnered with us and other
institutions generally that work with us
okay that's that's
good thank you and finally did this is
just
something that's come up from something
you've said uh in earlier evidence but
did credit suites
ever reject any paper that you offered
for securitization
yes they did uh and was that a regular
occurrence
i would uh
i would think it probably happened uh a
couple of times a month i would think
damn angela
and you may say well why was that not
more frequent
and the answer to that is that the funds
that credit suisse operated
had very clear rules around
the eligibility of assets that could go
into them
yeah we didn't change customers very
often because you'll appreciate
once you're financing the supply chain
of a company that
you kind of keep doing it for an
extended period of time
and so consequently um
it would be unusual for them to reject a
transaction most likely it might be if
it's a
for example a new customer um that
perhaps
they didn't adjudicate was within
the other rules but in terms of actual
limits those limits are just a
mathematical calculation
relative to the to information they've
told us as to
capacity and the rules of the fund so
obviously we wouldn't offer them
something that we knew to be in breach
of the
of the rules does that answer so they
turned you down sometimes what did you
then do with those
with those assets that you tried to
securitize
certainly credit suisse was definitely
the largest of our investors
dame angela um but it certainly was not
the only one
um there were 52 banks that bought
assets from us
and several thousand institutional
investors
who also bought assets from us including
many significant institutional investors
here in britain that you would you would
know well
um uh and so you know
an asset that was offered to them if
they declined it would would likely
end up being purchased either by winsor
bank or by one of the
dozens and dozens of other investors who
who purchased assets from us on a daily
basis
so your own bank purchased the assets if
you couldn't
send them perhaps to the credit suisse
funds
this is the bank that um the
bar finn of are now investigating isn't
it in germany
that is correct yeah and they're looking
at criminal
uh charges over there are they not
there have not been no criminal charges
laid against uh
staff of um of greensville bank but i've
certainly read of the
commentary in the uh in the press and
there are some
um german towns who invested
institutionally in that bank that lost a
lot of money as a result of what's
happened
i like you i have read that in the press
as well
yeah so there are more there's more than
one uh
loser here thank you very much chair
thanks angela and finally going to julie
thank you chair and um thank you mr
greensell um
just uh we're at the last hurdle i'd
just like to
recap the first questions that the chair
asked you about lord miners and your
meeting
and just to be very clear um lord miners
told this committee
i was contacted by somebody who said
that let's greenseal would like to meet
with me
so i went to meet with lex greensell
and am i correct in recalling your
answer saying almost the opposite
that someone told you that lord minus
wanted to meet with you
so that you look met with lord minor
correct
okay um what what did you why did you
want to
meet lord minus what were your motives
in taking that meeting
you're running a huge company you've got
other commitments i'm sure why
why would you want to meet someone who
was who has been
quite hostile asking very difficult
questions about your company
sure first of all
lord miners is uh a very respected
member of the financial establishment
an ex-regulator uh we were a growing
firm
he had as you said raised questions uh
about our firm and and and others in in
parliament
and uh so i was very keen
and very happy to uh to to meet with him
uh
because it gave us an opportunity to one
kind of
learn from his views and he has some
very clear views
around um the way that open-ended funds
and illiquid assets should interact with
with one another
which he's been outspoken on i was very
keen to ensure
that he understood the nature of our
business and the assets that we
purchased in our business
um and uh and so we had a a constructive
conversation around what his concerns
were
the way that our business worked um and
he noted
um that you know there are risks within
our business
but those risks were different to
perhaps
what he had initially anticipated or
viewed
that those those risks were um and i
certainly recognized that
uh there is and always is room for
continued um improvement in terms of
compliance
uh and as we were growing as a as a
business it was inevitable that
we were um moving into more regulated
spaces and therefore his his input was
invaluable
he he called you a very charming man did
you did you use your charm to
to kind of buy him off really get off
your back
i i told him the way our business was
and uh so if he regards that as charming
um i'm i'm gratified that that was uh
was his view
what was was the the offer of a job or
the talking you know the progressing of
an offer of a job
was that a genuine gap in your board
capability
or was that just an ad hoc well this
just occurred to me right now
this seems like a good idea
if you were to look at the composition
of our board you would see that we don't
have
anybody with a regulatory background
on our board and our business was
growing
it was heading in the direction of
potentially becoming a public company
and so therefore that expertise is
expertise that we saw as valuable
when lord miners
ultimately declined we ended up hiring a
very significant
regulatory expert as vice chairman of
our firm
um in his because lord miners didn't
uh take that position so i guess from
that perspective we were
hiring and we did hire a very
significant
person with with real credentials in in
that space
did you um relay the results of that
meeting
and give david cameron a mission to to
talk to david to lord myers
um we know that he ran into him at a
meeting some weeks
following that and made sure that he
spoke to him did you give david cameron
a mission
on that in that respect no i i don't
recall giving
david cameron bishop i'm not sure i ever
gave david cameron a mission
uh but uh um but
i believe that mr cameron uh met with
lord miners
uh in october 2019 and my meetings
uh as i as i mentioned to you earlier
were in in july and september of
2019. thank you one of the people who
did lobby big treasury on behalf of
grimsel was
uh bill crothers how did you come to
employ bill cruthers
so i met mr crubbers
in connection with the fact that he was
my memory serves me correctly he was the
senior civil servant responsible for the
crown
representative program of which i became
one
and when mr cruthers
ceased to be the
chief procurement officer as a chief
commercial officer i apologize uh of
uh in in the cabinet office um he
and a new person had been appointed to
that role
he was thinking of other things to to do
and
i invited him to be an advisor on a
part-time basis
um within our within our firm and uh he
started as a as an advisor to us um
after he
ceased to be the uh um the chief
commercial officer
he was still the government chief
procurement officer for at least
two months wasn't he when if there was
an overlap in that
uh time in the treasury which was being
referred to by civil servants is
extraordinary that that double hat
position was allowed to to happen i mean
did you did you think that was a
conflict of interest or did you just
think you were very lucky
mrs marston just just to be clear he was
no longer
the chief commercial officer or chief
procurement officer at the point that he
became
a part-time advisor to greensville
there was no overlap so the discussion
he continued to
he was still an employee of the civil
service
but he was no longer the the chief
commercial officer he's my
recollection of events what was what was
his role um
in the civil service at the time you
employed him then just to be clear
i don't actually know what his title and
role was
but uh i think he was in a process of um
kind of helping his uh um replacement
with their transition but but
to be open with you uh ms mars
i'm speculating when i when i say that i
can
find out exactly for you and provide you
with a written answer if that would be
helpful to you in the community
that would be very helpful because there
has been a lot of comment about the
those dual responsibilities that
potential conflict of interest the
double hattie and it has been described
i think it was in
a previous committee it was described by
current civil servants as quite
extraordinary
that that was allowed to happen so
that's been talked about as if
that was actually happening um i mean it
might it
might have preempted the next question
which was really did you ask jeremy
haywood
or john manzoni who was obviously um
uh the head of the civil service uh
there the chief executive to approve
that that position that that overlap
that double hatting
situation absolutely not
okay thank you um mr crother's
consultancy was called commercial common
sense
is that the vehicle that you paid him
via was that the
entity that you paid him to
uh i i
don't know the answer to that question
off the top of my head
that wasn't a detail i came armed with
today
my recollection was that he started out
when he was part-time
through a consultancy entity but he
became an employee
um and at the time that uh um he was
full-time he was a an employee of our
company and at the time of the
um company going into administration he
was still an employee of the company
um and what did he do for you over this
period
sure i think one
important detail to to share with you is
that
again the time that uh
he left the civil service or ceased to
be a civil service employee was in
november 2015
and the first uk government contract
that we funded on was in
i believe july 2018
um but bill cluther's role was to assist
us
with bringing order to
our sales function on a global basis
and he had a role with us once he became
a full-time employee uh of uh of
actually heading up
our what we call origination which is
kind of
fancy speak for sales um so basically
oversaw the
the the client interactions that our
firm had with with
clients around the world but
that doesn't really kind of um cover the
fact that he was lobbying for great
green cell as well
what kind of lobbying activities did he
do what did he
what did you want him to do but that
related to his role as well in his
previous role within the
civil service uh
mr crothers wasn't lobbying government
we didn't actually have any government
business
uh for the two and a half years after he
joined uh our company so
his focus was on private sector um
now after we won the first
contract that we had with with the uk
government which i should emphasize was
one contrary to what was said in this
committee two weeks ago
was won through a very intensive
competitive
process indeed the actual betting of
that contract
was actually conducted as a straight out
auction
on price where our pricing was 40
lower than the incumbent um and was the
the basis on which we were
ultimately selected but after that
program was in place
mr cruthers then worked within a
leadership role
within our earned business which was the
the product that was
providing daily pay to employees
both within the nhs but but actually
also we were
aiming to to develop that for the
private sector as well
okay thank you very much i think i'm out
of time thank you chair
thanks very much julie i'd just like to
quickly follow up on the lobbying
questions
here lex um and go back to my earlier
question right at the start so
i think you said that the first time
that you realized that green saw was
really in trouble was
at the end of 2020 i think you may have
said december which
is also exactly the time that david
cameron
says he first became aware that
greenswar was in trouble
in his letter his recent letter to me he
says the first time i became concerned
that the company might be in serious
financial difficulty was in december
2020 following a call i received from
lex greensell now that of course is
quite distant from the period during
which the actual lobbying
was being carried out and hence my
earlier questions about uh what the
motivation for the lobbying and trying
to
tap into ccff was at that point i think
uh you went as far as to suggest that
with the pandemic which of course ended
up causing lots of problems for
green sill um it was helpful it would
have been helpful if
ccf ccff access had been achieved
in terms of um providing additional
security for the business giving the
uncertainties
ahead was that a discussion you had with
david cameron at that
time so did you share those fears with
him about
the uncertainty going forward and the
impact it might have on the business
and therefore the fact that access to
ccff
might have been useful in that specific
respect
mr cameron and i talked about the fact
that there was
uncertainty uh in capital market
liquidity
and that could absolutely affect our
clients uh
as ultimately and the numbers prove this
uh the volume of receivables that we
purchased
in 2019 was 143 billion us dollars
and the amount that we bought in 2020
incidentally enough
is actually also chester whisker over
143 billion
dollars so in fact
the events of covert uh
meant that we were able to provide the
same quantum of liquidity
to our customers over the course of 2020
as we did in
2019 in spite of the eruptions in the
market but we didn't know
in march and april um
exactly what the future would hold i'm
not sure that entirely answers my
question let me rephrase it so
what i'm saying is perhaps put it this
way would it be fair to say
that your motivation personally in uh
lobbying the treasury over ccff
was yes about providing support for smes
but it was also about providing that
additional safeguard given the
uncertainties
uh that they could well have been around
the business at that time
and that would also be the motivation of
mr cameron
at that point that he would have been
concerned to have got that support
on the basis that the business needed a
little more certainty a little more
shoring up
um than was the case at that particular
time with the pandemic
taking off mr chairman we had
just uh received
um more than one and a half billion
dollars of equity investment
from softbank vision fund only a few
months before that
there was absolutely no risk to
greenfield the company
our concern was making sure that there
were
alternative sources of capital available
if
capital markets continued to be in a
distressed
state yeah so it was a kind of hedge
against what might happen if things
kind of went the wrong way yeah and that
was the reason that the bank of england
put the ccff in place was uh and and why
many corporates signed up for it but
then ultimately did not use it because
they regarded that as a a safety
mechanism i guess for one of a better
word
mr chairman thank you that brings us to
the end of this session you're probably
quite relieved about that
mr greensall but thank you very much
indeed
uh for uh appearing before us we've
covered a lot of ground
today you very generously and kindly
said that you will write to us on
various matters
um i think probably a good way to
proceed here will be for us to write to
you in very short order
setting out the things that we believe
you've agreed
to write to us upon and also perhaps to
ask some other questions that may occur
to us uh after
um this session um it's been quite
robust and i think in
in some parts it's been a very robust
session but nonetheless we are a
courteous committee so we do appreciate
you having uh put yourself
uh before us uh today and for having
answered
the questions uh that you have that
concludes this session
order order
thank you chap
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended